Tja, so klang das damals im Jahr 2012, als Michel Platini, damals noch UEFA-Präsident, der Öffentlichkeit zum allerersten Mal seine Idee präsentierte. Eine Europameisterschaft, die nicht von einem Land als Gastgeber betrieben wird, sondern in mehreren Ländern stattfindet. Und wie ihr hört, hat er auch die vermeintliche Reaktion der Berichtenden vor Ort schon vorweggenommen mit seinem Ah, ja, so hat man damals reagiert. Und jetzt findet genau eine solche EM statt, ohne Michel Platini als UEFA-Präsident. Das ist schon wieder Geschichte. Da sitzt jetzt jemand anderes und auch nicht ganz, so wie es sich Platini vorgestellt hat, ein bisschen weniger Nationen sind es geworden. Aber jetzt haben wir sie eben, diese EM in verschiedenen Ländern. Und da sind durchaus auch Länder mit dabei, die jetzt nicht nur durch Sport aufgefallen sind in der Vergangenheit. Und darum wollen wir uns heute kümmern in diesem Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch Nummer 44, zu dem ich euch ganz herzlich begrüße. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Etkin Etzer bei Twitter und ich freue mich sehr, den perfekten Gesprächspartner für dieses Spiel, für dieses Spiel, für dieses Tribünengespräch zu haben. Ronny Blaschke, er ist freier Journalist und Autor. Er hat geschrieben, unter anderem sein jüngstes Buch Machtspieler Fußball in Propaganda, Krieg und Revolution. Er hat auch geschrieben Gesellschaftsspielchen, Fußball zwischen Hilfsbereitschaft und Heuchelei, sowie zum Beispiel Angriff von Rechtsaußen wie Neonazis, den Fußballmissbrauchen. Also die richtigen gute Launenthemen, die packt sich der Ronny immer raus. Ronny, schön, dass du mit dabei bist im Rasenfunk.
Hallo Max, vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Wie hat sich denn das entwickelt, dass du immer über solche Themen recherchierst und veröffentlichst?
Das war eigentlich nicht der Plan. Ich bin großer Fußballfan gewesen. Ich bin in der Nähe von Rostock aufgewachsen, in einer kleinen Stadt, habe auch selbst Fußball gespielt, war Torwart und wollte eigentlich Sportreporter werden als Teenager, um meinem Lieblingsverein Hansa Rostock nahe zu sein. Also wie Thomas Kisten, der von der Süddeutschen Zeitung gesagt hat, kostenfrei ins Stadion hinter die Absperrung. Aber dann sind einige Jahre vergangen und die Szenen haben sich wiederholt. Ich konnte jetzt nicht jedes Jahr emotional sein oder traurig sein. Und dann habe ich mir über den Fußball auch andere Themen erschlossen. In meiner Familie, da war Politik, da war das nicht ein ganz großes Thema. Und das habe ich mir seltsamerweise über den Fußball irgendwie erschlossen, weil nicht nur in Rostock, sondern auch in vielen anderen Städten, da gab es Probleme noch mit den Hooligans oder auch mit rechten Fans. Und das hat mich interessiert. Am Anfang ein Diffus, aber ich habe das dann weiter für mich erschlossen und vor allem viele interessante, spannende Leute in Fanszenen, in Fanprojekten kennengelernt. Und so ist das über die Jahre immer weitergegangen, bis jetzt eben zu diesem internationaleren Weg im Fußball.
Ich finde das halt so interessant, weil du so deutlich herausstichst aus der Masse an Sportjournalistinnen und Journalisten eben allein mit deiner Themenwahl. Und ich habe jetzt ja noch gar nicht alle Bücher aufgezählt, die du geschrieben hast und bei weitem natürlich nicht die ganzen Artikel, die du auch noch dazu verfasst. Was glaubst du denn, woran liegt denn das, dass diese großen Themen, für die man ja auch viel Recherchezeit braucht, dass die eher von weniger Leuten beackert werden?
Was im Sport ja einmalig ist, auch gegenüber Politik, Wirtschaft oder Kultur, ist, dass die großen Fernsehsender die Rechteinhaber ja erst mal Geld bezahlen, damit sie überhaupt vom Fußball berichten dürfen. Also die Mehrheit hat also gar kein Interesse, sein eigenes Produkt irgendwie schlecht zu reden. Das sind zum einen die Rechteinhaber, dann haben wir die reichweitenstarken Boulevard-Medien, das hat man in Corona gesehen. Auch die haben gezittert, wenn es keinen Fußball gibt, dann haben sie keine Klicks, dann haben sie keine Auflage. Und bei mir war das ja auch so, dass man nicht mit dem Interesse Sportreporter wird, um Missstände aufzudecken, sondern eher, weil man eine eigene Nähe, eine eigene Vorliebe für den Sport hat. Und das ist in Politik und Wirtschaft komplett anders. Das ist aber nicht mehr ganz so schlimm wie vor 15 oder 20 Jahren. Also ich glaube, so Kollegen wie Thomas Kistner, wie Hajo Seppelt, die haben dann schon einen wichtigen Weg geebnet. Und jetzt haben wir mit Sport in Zeit beim WDR, meine Kollegen beim Deutschlandfonds, für die ich viel arbeite, oder auch die FAZ, die Süddeutsche, da gibt es ja mittlerweile der Spiegel, da gibt es ja einige Kolleginnen, die da einiges leisten. Das ist nicht mehr so wie vor 10, 15 Jahren, aber ich würde auch schon sagen, das kann doch mehr werden. Und was auch interessant ist, dass es ja oftmals so Sondereien gibt, wie Sport in Zeit, wie Kontraste, Panorama, die Politikmagazine machen häufig auch solche Themen. Aber in die Premiumstrecken, ins Sportstudio, in die Sportschau, in den Doppelpass, da dringen die kritischen Themen nicht so richtig rein. Aber vielleicht wäre das dann die nächste Etappe der Entwicklung.
Ja, mal gucken, wann es dazu kommt. Da habe ich noch so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, zumindest bei manchem der Formate, die du da gerade als Premiumstrecken bezeichnet hast. Wir wollen da gleich mal näher einsteigen ins Thema. Vorher muss ich mich aber noch bedanken bei einer Reihe von Menschen. Das ist in diesem Fall Halvo Hal, Stuttgarter, Kegelspiel, Rastorf, Dr. Trost, Laternenmensch, Andreas Basel, Fritters in Schanghai, Raffi89, Dorfkicker Schmitzel, Tüzi Rohl und Gregor. Sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter und unterstützen den Rasenfunk finanziell. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-sponsoren- und werbefrei. Wir finanzieren uns allein über euch da draußen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und auch unsere Gäste bekommen ein Honorar, wenn auch noch nicht ganz auf Deutschlandfunkmaß stehen. Aber da kommen wir hoffentlich mit eurer Hilfe hin, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Und das gehört ja auch ein bisschen dazu, dass man berichten kann darüber, worüber man möchte, wenn man nicht eine Abhängigkeit hat zu Sponsoren. Also da kommt das ja beim Rasenfunk auch her, ohne dass sie jetzt unsere Arbeit mit einer gleichsetzen möchte. Das wäre dann doch etwas vermessen. Dann habe ich noch Ankündigungen zu machen. Und zwar, das hier ist ja ein erstes Tribünengespräch in unserer EM-Berichterstattung. Die hat schon begonnen mit der Schlusskonferenz einer EM-Vorschau auf alle 24 Teams. Und sie wird weitergehen mit täglichen Kurzpässen. Das heißt, wenn ihr den Rasenfunk-Kurzpass noch nicht abonniert habt, tut das. Ab dem ersten Spieltag geht es los. Wir besprechen alle Spiele und zu den deutschen Spielen gibt es noch Schlusskonferenzen. Es gibt auch EM-Tipp-Spiele, einfach Rasenfunk 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Je nachdem, was noch frei ist, könnt ihr auf kicktip.de mal suchen. Und ihr könnt sehr gern unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de nicht nur Feedback zu dieser Sendung geben, sondern euch auch an der Erstellung der kommenden Sendungen beteiligen. Da freue ich mich sehr darüber. Und weil wir eben diesen sportlichen Aspekt jetzt dann in den nächsten Wochen so zu Tode reiten werden im Rasenfunk. Und weil ich da dann auch gar nicht so sehr weiß, was dann meine Rolle als Moderator ist, wie oft ich dann auf die Bezüge dahinter verweisen soll, kann und auch werde in den Sendungen. Deshalb gibt es jetzt dieses Tribünengespräch. Und ich bin sehr froh, Ronny, dass du dafür Zeit hast. Denn Fußball und die Politik, das gehört schon länger zusammen. Und in aktuellen Zeiten ist es eigentlich sogar fast kaum mehr voneinander zu trennen. In unterschiedlichen Abstufungen, würde ich sagen, je nach Land und je nach Sportbegeisterung. Was glaubst du denn, woher kommt denn das, dass der Fußball so interessant ist für die Politik?
Seit es den Fußball gibt, also seit weit mehr als 100 Jahren, war der Fußball immer auch politisch. Ich habe ja für das Buch in viele Länder geschaut, auf viele Kontinente. Und das war immer so. Und in der Gegenwart ist es auch in Europa bei der EM so. Also wir haben jetzt dieses Jubiläum, was eigentlich damit gefeiert werden sollte, dass es quer über den Kontinent verteilt ist. Und so kommen eben auch kleinere Städte in den Genuss, wie Kopenhagen oder auch Bukarest oder Budapest, die natürlich keine eigene EM stemmen könnten. Und was ganz charmant gewesen ist, da kommen jetzt eben auch so autokratische Regierungschefs und Nutzen den Fußball. Aber vielleicht ein Beispiel gleich am Anfang, weil es die Schlagzeilen seit Monaten, seit Wochen uns verfolgen, ist Belarus. Ja, ein Land, was jetzt nicht bei der EM dabei ist, aber Alexander Lukaschenko, der Präsident der sogenannten letzten Diktatur, da sieht man, dass Fußball, dass Sport und Politik manchmal sogar ein und dasselbe sind. Weil Lukaschenko war lange nämlich auch Präsident des nationalen olympischen Komitees. Der hat Sportler, der hat Fußballer sozusagen als Staatsbotschafter genutzt, hat viel Geld da investiert, hat Vertraute aus dem Militär, aus Staatsbetrieben, in die Führungsgremien gesetzt. Und dann hat er sich aber doch gewundert, dass mit den Protesten nach der gefälschten Präsidentschaft auch viele Sportler protestiert haben, die nicht nur ihre Karriere, sondern auch ihre Gesundheit riskiert haben, verhaftet wurden, gefoltert wurden. Weniger die Fußballfans, denn das ist interessant, denn die wurden nämlich in den vergangenen Jahren schon systematisch zerschlagen, eingeschüchtert bedroht. Ein Fußballfan ist sogar tot aufgefunden worden nach Demonstrationen. Man mutmaßt, dass er von der Polizei verschleppt wurde und zu Tode gekommen ist. Also da sieht man eines von ganz vielen Beispielen in Belarus. Ja, das Sport und Politik, weil es eben so vermeintlich unpolitisch ist. Da kann man gesellschaftsübergreifend so viele Menschen erreichen und es wirkt relativ unideologisch. Aber wir wissen natürlich, dass das Gegenteil der Fall ist.
Und kommt das dann daher einfach nur, weil der Fußball so beliebt ist, zumindest jetzt über die Länder, über die wir jetzt hier sprechen? Also vielleicht ist das dann in Indien Cricket. Ich weiß es nicht. Da kenne ich mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht gut genug aus. Also ist er deswegen als Projektionsfläche für Politik so wichtig, weil Politik ja letztlich auch viel mit Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie zu tun hat. Und da hat man eben dann im Fußball eine sehr prominente Plattform, bei der man weiß, für die interessiert sich sehr viele Menschen im Land.
Es ist so, dass eigentlich in den mehr als 200 Mitgliedsländern des Weltverbandes FIFA, da könnte man auf jeden Fall immer dieses politische Vergrößerungsglas anlegen. Und man würde sehen, ich würde gerne der Erste sein, der im Rasenfunk über Cricket spricht. Weil ich habe nämlich im vergangenen Jahr ein größeres Stück gemacht. Und klar ist Cricket in einigen Ländern der wichtigste Sport. Und gerade die Atommächte Indien und Pakistan, die haben immer wieder im Cricket gezeigt, wie sie ihre Anfeindungen loswerden, wie sie aber auch wieder sich annähern können. Mehrere Spitzenpolitiker, wie der Premierminister von Pakistan, früherer Cricket-Spieler. Also dort, wo die wichtigsten Sportarten sind, das kann in anderen Ländern auch Karate sein oder wie auch immer. Aber Cricket ist ein Beispiel. Und Fußball auch. Wenn wir mal zurückschauen, wo kommt der Fußball her? Großbritannien und die Briten, große Kolonialmacht, die wollten mit ihren Sportarten wie Fußball, Cricket, Tennis, Rugby, die wollten ihren Sport verbreiten. Aber sie wollten natürlich auch ihre, Zitat, untergebenen, ein bisschen auch zivilisieren mit dem britischen Ethos versehen. Und da haben sie eben auch manchmal in den Kolonien den Fußball genutzt. Oder eben auch andere Sportarten. Ich war in Singapur im vergangenen Jahr. Da ist eines der teuersten Grundstücke im Zentrum von Singapur ein Cricket Ground. Wo quasi noch die alte Kolonie immer noch ein bisschen überlebt hat. Also der Sport, der Fußball, wie auch andere Sportarten, die sind, muss man nicht immer politisch nennen, aber in der Alltagskultur sozusagen eingebrannt. Und dann können Politiker, können alle ihre Projektionsfläche darauf werfen und sich ihr Stück dann da rausziehen.
Ohne jetzt das Tribünengespräch Fußball und Politik machen zu wollen, da müsste man nämlich noch ein bisschen tiefer einsteigen. Aber was ich interessant finde, ist, wenn ich mir das so im Schnelldurchlauf betrachte, du hast jetzt eben Großbritannien und seinen Einfluss dabei, wie sich eben der Fußball verbreitet hat, genannt, dann sieht man ja, dass es gerade am Anfang, vor allem in Kontinentaleuropa, auch gerade hier in Deutschland sehr viele Gegenbewegungen zum Fußball gab. Also dass das gar nicht so gerne gesehen war, auch oft aus ideologischen Gründen, weil man geglaubt hat, also in Deutschland hatten wir den Turnvater Jan und der Einzelsport war wichtiger. Und es gab ganz viele Länder, die das auch eher so unter militärischen Aspekten betrachtet haben, gesagt haben, das wäre nicht gut für die Moral dieses Spiel, was sich dann irgendwann sogar verdreht hat, verkehrt hat. Also wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war es dann unter anderem auch in der Sowjetunion irgendwann so, dass man dann im Gegenteil gesehen hat, ne, so gerade diese Mannschaftssportart, die einen auch auf andere Gedanken bringt, ist dann auch ganz gut fürs Gemeinschaftsgefühl. Und es gibt ja sogar dieses berühmte Weihnachtsspiel, das war jetzt im Ersten Weltkrieg noch, jetzt bin ich ein bisschen in den Zeiten gesprungen, ich gebe es zu. Aber was ich interessant finde, ist, dass da so eine Dynamik drin war im Umgang der Politik mit dem Fußball. Und dass es dann aber schon, glaube ich, relativ früh angefangen hat, nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, dass in vielen Ländern der Fußball sich als populärste Sportart wieder erneut durchgesetzt hat oder zum ersten Mal so richtig aufblühen konnte. Würdest du denn sagen, wenn wir uns diese Zeiten betrachten, dann so ab dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, hat sich der Umgang der Politik mit dem Fußball jetzt nochmal zu dem, über das wir jetzt gleich sprechen werden, verändert? Oder ist das einfach nur alter Wein in neuen Schläuchen?
Ja, ich würde, es ist schwer, da Länder und Regionen und Kontinente zu vergleichen. Das ist sicherlich, muss man da von Land zu Land schauen. Ich habe gerade die Kolonialmächte angesprochen, wenn man vielleicht nochmal beim Thema bleibt, nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, 50er, 60er Jahre, als dann die großen Unabhängigkeitsbewegungen in Afrika begonnen haben. Ich habe Algerien zum Beispiel, war mehr als 100 Jahre unter französischer Besatzung. Und dann in den 50er Jahren, viele algerischstämmige Spieler waren auch in Frankreich. Und als dann die Befreiungsbewegung in Algerien groß geworden ist, da sind etliche Spieler aus Frankreich zurück nach Algerien gegangen, haben sie zu einem Fußballteam versammelt und sind dann als Werbeträger durch die Welt gereist und haben mit Fußballspielen für die Unabhängigkeit von Algerien geworben. Einige haben auch wirklich am Krieg sich beteiligt. Und die Hymne der damaligen Mannschaft, die ist jetzt immer noch die Hymne des Landes. Und da kann man eigentlich auch in andere Länder gehen, in Kamerun, im Kongo. Also da gibt es wirklich legendäre Spiele und legendäre Fußballmannschaften. Vieles ist natürlich auch Verklärung und Romantisierung. Ich war auch in Ruanda für das Buch. Da haben zum einen die Völkermörder vom Genozid gegen die Tutsi, haben im Fußball ihre Kämpfe rekrutiert. Aber auch die Rebellenarmee, des jetzigen Staatspräsidenten Paul Kagame. Auch der hat Anfang der 90er-Jahre ein Fußballteam gegründet, weil er seine Soldaten auch bei Laune halten wollte. Sein Team ist aktuell der Rekordmeister in Ruanda, weil der natürlich immer noch vom Militär unterstützt wird und die Gunst hat. Aber das sind einzelne Beispiele, das ist schwer immer zu vergleichen. Es bewegt sich auch in Wellen und ist vielleicht auch besser organisiert jetzt. Das gilt vor allem auch für die Länder und für die Politiker, über die wir sicherlich noch sprechen werden.
Dann lass uns doch vielleicht mal mit dem einsteigen, weil das Thema Fußballpolitik ist so groß, dass wir uns jetzt beschränken wollen auf die Europameisterschaft und auf Teilnehmerländer und was es dazu zu sagen gibt. Weil du dazu eben auch viel in deinem Buch Machtspieler recherchiert hast. Was ich sehr empfehlen möchte, ist erschienen im Werkstattverlag. Ich hoffe sehr, die Hörerinnen und Hörer lesen da nach dieser Folge noch rein. Ganz viele Dinge werden wir auch auslassen, weil wir uns jetzt eben auf die Europameisterschaft beschränken. Es begann ja erst mal mit dieser Idee, dass die ja schon politische Hintergründe hatte, aber sportpolitische Hintergründe, nämlich dieses Turnier in mehreren Ländern veranstalten zu wollen. Das hat Michel Platini wahrscheinlich nicht nur deshalb als Idee gehabt, weil es damals gar nicht so einfach war, noch Gastgeberländer zu finden. Es war eine Zeit der wirtschaftlichen Krise. Da haben jetzt nicht alle gleich hier gerufen, als es um die Ausrichtung eines großen Turniers ging. Aber es hatte ja sehr wahrscheinlich auch damit zu tun, dass er sich bei den kleineren Nationen für seine Wahl zum UEFA-Präsident damit bedanken wollte. Und damit können ja auch viele Länder an einem wirtschaftlich sehr lukrativen Event teilnehmen. Also die EM 2016, die hat 1,9 Milliarden Euro eingenommen bei 1,1 Milliarden Ausgaben. Das heißt, 800 Millionen hat man da Gewinn gemacht. Glaubst du, diese wirtschaftliche Seite ist dann der Hauptfaktor gewesen, warum das interessant ist? Oder ist es dann sogar bei den Beispielen, über die wir gleich sprechen werden, sogar nachgelagert?
Ich weiß noch, als Michel Platini zum ersten Mal in der Öffentlichkeit darüber gesprochen hat, das war bei der Bilanzpressekonferenz der Europameisterschaft 2012, damals in Polen und in der Ukraine. Diese Pressekonferenz war in Kiew. Wir saßen dann da im Saal und haben uns angeguckt. Ich fand die Idee eigentlich immer ganz charmant. Das war schon damals die Zeit, wo sich der Rechtsruck in einigen Ländern abgezeichnet hat, wo rechtspopulistische Parteien entstanden sind. Österreich, in Frankreich, ohnehin immer mal wieder in Ungarn, auch in Skandinavien. Und warum nicht auch in Europa mal in einem relativ kleinen Kontinent dann nicht mal so ein Turnier? Und natürlich, die EM ist rasant gewachsen. Sponsoren kommen mittlerweile auch aus Ländern außerhalb von Europa. Das ist vielleicht unter dem Gesichtspunkt der Nachhaltigkeit gar nicht so schlecht, weil nicht jetzt die großen neuen Stadien gebaut werden müssen. Klar sind die Flugdistanzen mitunter weit weg, aber letztendlich hat man sich doch schon mit dem Gedanken angefreundet, diesen europäischen Gedanken. Aber natürlich ist der Nachteil, dass sich eben dann auch Regime wie in Aserbaidschan da sonnen können. St. Petersburg ist wieder dabei, auch Budapest ist dabei. Aber wir haben eine Gelegenheit jetzt darüber zu sprechen und mal auch die sportpolitischen Systeme da mal ein bisschen genauer uns anzuschauen. Das ist doch vielleicht auch nicht so schlecht.
Das ist auch die perfekte Überleitung. Dann lass uns genau damit beginnen. Ich würde gerne mit St. Petersburg und Russland als Ausrichter starten. Da gibt es ja erstmal schon mal die Besonderheit, dass die EM das erste große Sport-Event ist, das in Russland stattfindet, seitdem der internationale Sportgerichtshof Kass wegen des umfangreichen Staatsdropping-Systems einen zweijährigen Ausrichter-Bann verfügt hat. Warum geht das dann? Weil die EM als regionales kontinentales Ereignis klassifiziert wurde. Deswegen ist man von diesem Bann ausgenommen. Da steckt dann schon gleich ein zweites Thema drin, Doping. Aber lass mal generell damit anfangen. Kann man sagen, dass Vladimir Putin, seitdem er russischer Präsident wurde, 1999, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, dass er so ein bisschen der Vorreiter dafür ist, wie man den Sport generell und damit auch den Fußball politisch instrumentalisieren kann für die eigenen Zwecke?
Ja, also ich würde sagen, Vladimir Putin war nach diesen turbulenten Jahren in den 90er Jahren unter Boris Yeltsin, als Russland eine große Wirtschaftskrise hatte, wo man einfach das Bedürfnis hatte, wieder eine starke Macht zu sein, anerkannt in der Welt. Und da hat Vladimir Putin zunächst als Ministerpräsident, später als Präsident, auch in Abwechslung mit Medvedev, immer wieder auch den Fußball als ein Element angesehen. Und das hat er damals auch, als viele Oligarchen zum Macht und Geld gekommen sind, dann auch immer eingesetzt. Gazprom, als der größte Gasproduzent Staatskonzern Russland, spielt eine wichtige Rolle, hat nicht nur Putins Club aus seiner Heimatstadt, also Zenit St. Petersburg ins Spitzenfeld geführt, ist auch Sponsor bei Schalke 04, bei Roter Stern Belgrad, seit 2012 auch von der Europäischen Champions League, UEFA und FIFA auch. Das ist ein Beispiel, wie Gazprom oder Russland an sich über Geld, über den Fußball in diplomatische politische Netzwerke eindringen, die sie vielleicht auf dem normalen Wege nicht bekommen würden. Ich will jetzt gar nicht diesen Weg öffnen mit diesen ganzen umstrittenen Gas-Pipeline-Projekten. Da werden die Gazprom-Manager es nicht so leicht haben, in westliche Demokratien Termine zu bekommen. Aber vielleicht in der WIP-Tribüne bei Schalke oder bei der Champions League. Wir werden ja seit langem mit diesen Gazprom-Spots behällig. Das ist ein Element. Natürlich haben wir oft schon gehört, die WM 2018, die Winterspiele Olympia 2014, ganz viele Weltmeisterschaften, Biathlon, Schwimmen und so weiter. Das hat alles Russland veranstaltet. Nicht immer nur, damit wir begeistert sind, sondern dieses riesige Land mit mehr als 100 Volksgruppen, was immer noch nach einem gemeinsamen Narrativ sucht nach dem Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion. Da kann Sport vorübergehend mal so ein Kit darstellen. Und man darf auch nicht vergessen, Russland ist nicht nur Moskau, ist nicht nur Putin. Das sind viele Regionen, das sind autonome Republiken. Das ist Tschechenien, Ramsan Kadirov, der auch den Fußball nutzt, indem er für viel Geld manchmal Fußballer einfliegen lässt in Tschechenien. Und die wollen alle mit Fußball ein bisschen ein Stück haben vom Kuchen, wollen Touristenanwerben, wollen Fachkräfte, wollen Start-ups und so weiter. Die Regionen stehen auch in Konkurrenz zueinander. Und Putin lässt sie gewähren und der Sport hilft als Kit. Und da ist das jetzt fast noch eine kleinere Baustelle. Die EM im kommenden Jahr findet St. Petersburg das Champions League-Finale statt. Aber ich glaube, Putin hat die Maßstäbe gesetzt, wie man den Fußball, den Sport einbetten kann in die Sportpolitik. Jetzt haben sie sich aufgeregt, dass die Ukraine auf dem Trikot oder in der Symbolik die Landkarte mit der Krim zeigt, also die Russland 2014 völkerrechtsmietrig annektiert hat. So groß ist der Widerstand jetzt nicht bei anderen Sportmächten. Russland ist, muss man sagen, aus russischer Logik heraus, sehr clever vernetzt in den Sportgremien, in den Verbänden, in den wirtschaftlichen Netzwerken. Ob die jetzt bei Olympia nicht dabei sein dürfen oder mit einer anderen Flagge auftreten, Russland ist nach wie vor präsent. Und die, die Sport super macht, glaube ich, auch eine der Sport-Supermächte der Gegenwart.
Also wir haben jetzt schon so ganz viele Aspekte, warum Vladimir Putin oder zu welchem Zweck er mutmaßlich den Sport verwendet, schon so angerissen. Da würde ich gerne mal noch ein bisschen eintauchen. Und vielleicht aber erstmal anfangen mit einer Einschränkung, beziehungsweise der Frage nach einer Einschränkung. Grundsätzlich würde man ja jetzt auch, wenn man über deutsche Politiker spricht, jetzt nicht davon reden, dass die sich vom Sport distanzieren, sondern die verwenden ja auch den Sport als Plattform. Also ich weiß gar nicht, mit wie vielen unterschiedlichen Fans Charles Mann Martin Schulz während des Bundestagswahlkampf damals gesehen hat, als der Schulz-Zug mal ganz kurz losrollte, bevor er dann auch schon ausrollte relativ schnell. Wie unterscheidet sich denn das, was du jetzt da schon angerissen hast, wo wir gleich noch eintauchen, was Vladimir Putin macht von dem, was wir ja vielleicht in allen anderen westlichen Demokratien auch sehen?
Absolut. Also natürlich ist Fußball auch in westlichen Ländern von Politikern. Wir erinnern uns an Berlusconi in Mailand. Der hat seinen Medienkonzern mit dem Fußball, mit seiner Partei verschmelzen lassen. Es gibt einige Clubs in England, Glaser in Manchester, JP Morgan, die aus den USA wollte jetzt die Super League finanzieren. Natürlich haben die auch wirtschaftliche Interessen und politische Netzwerke wollen sie auch knüpfen. Legendär, darauf werde ich ganz oft angesprochen, ist, wenn ich mal wieder angeblich nur über die Nicht-Westler herziehe. Das kommt schon auch in Vorträgen und Veranstaltungen oft, warum ich so wenig auf den Westen schaue. Deswegen schön, dass du das gleich mal ansprichst. Es ist so, dass wir reden oft über dieses Foto von Angela Merkel und Joachim Gauck 2014 nach dem WM-Sieg in Rio de Janeiro. Der Unterschied ist aber, dass wir uns jetzt noch darüber lustig machen können, dass wir in Deutschland zumindest noch einige mitgliedsgeführte Vereine haben, dass man sich da einbringen kann, dass man das auch auswerten kann. Ich würde mir persönlich noch mehr wünschen, dass die Politik auch eine Kontrollfunktion hat und nicht wie im vergangenen Jahr, dass Armin Laschet und Markus Söder als Ministerpräsidenten gemeinsam mit der Bild-Zeitung für eine frühe Wiederaufnahme der Bundesliga werden, weil sie Hoffnung haben, damit Wählerschichten zu mobilisieren. Natürlich wollen hier auch das ganze politische Parteien, Politiker den Fußball nutzen. Aber es gibt auch eine sehr gut organisierte, verzweigte, zivilgesellschaftliche Fanszene, die da sich ganz doll aufregen kann und Bündnisse schmieden kann. Und das ist in Russland, das ist in Katar und das ist in China nicht der Fall.
Also der Unterschied liegt quasi in der Art und Weise, in der Kontext, in dem das Ganze stattfindet, ist dann eben entscheidend. Wie sieht denn dann der Kontext in Russland aus? Wenn wir mal vielleicht erstmal bei dem bleiben, was du zum einen als Kitt der Gesellschaft beschrieben hast. Und das Wort Zivilgesellschaft spielt ja auch eine ganz wichtige Rolle in deinem Buch. Was sind denn da die Problematiken, die relevant sind im Kontext Fußball?
In Russland, und ich habe mir fest vorgenommen, nicht immer so negativ zu sein, sondern eben auch konstruktiv. Ich war auch vor der WM 2018 mehrfach in Russland und wollte immer auch Menschen besuchen und vorstellen, die den Fußball da auch als Plattform nutzen. Also es ist nicht wie in Katar oder in China. Es gab und gibt in Russland immer weniger, aber es gibt sie Bündnisse, die sich für Offenheit, für Toleranz auch. Der LGBTIQ-Sportverband gibt es dort. Und viele zivilgesellschaftliche Bündnisse, auch Gewerkschaften, auch deutsche Organisationen, gelten als sogenannte ausländische Agenten. Die werden gefilzt, die werden besucht, die werden oftmals abgehört, die werden schikaniert. Und das habe ich öfter gehört, dass zum Beispiel dieser LGBTIQ-Sportverband, der erst mal über eine gesunde Ernährung, Bewegung, Vernetzung kommt und der nicht so sehr unter Beobachtung steht, weil er eben ein Sportverband ist. Und in Russland ist es noch nicht so wie bei uns. Da kann man manchmal noch leichter durchschlüpfen. Das gilt auch für Frauenrechtsbewegungen, die sich den Sport dazu eigen gemacht haben. Also dieser Begriff des Politischen, den wir in Deutschland ja oftmals auch mit Stolz sagen und dass der Fußball sich engagiert für Erinnerungskultur und so weiter. Dieser Begriff Politische ist eigentlich in einigen Ländern Osteuropas, auch in Russland, verbrannt, weil viele Menschen das gleichsetzen mit Machterhalt und Korruption und Putin und Wirtschaftseliten und Oligarchie. Aber trotzdem kann der Fußball, der Sport dort auch Leute vernetzen. Das ist natürlich ein tolles Projekt. Möchte ich erwähnen, Fankurve Ost, Kollegen wie Ingo Petz, die in diesem Projekt Journalisten, Fans und andere aus Belarus, Ukraine und Russland immer wieder auch zusammenbringen und tolle Projekte machen. Das ist in Russland auch möglich. Was jetzt im Nachhinein der WM passiert, das müssen wir mal abwarten. Aber es sieht ja so aus, dass mit der EM und auch nächstes Jahr mit dem Champions-League-Finale das normalisiert ist, der Fußball und die Politik in Russland.
Das waren jetzt quasi positive Beispiele, wie der Fußball der Zivilgesellschaft helfen kann, auch für die Rechte von Minderheiten einzutreten oder auf Missstände hinzuweisen. Gerade Frauenrechte sind ein extrem spannendes Thema, wenn man über Russland spricht. Auch weil es eine ganz andere Tradition da hat als zum Beispiel auch hier in Deutschland. Und zwar eine viel länger und weiter zurückreichende Tradition, was vielleicht gar nicht so jedem bewusst ist. Jetzt haben wir aber auch schon mal mit mehreren Großereignissen, also Vladimir Putin hat die Dekade des Sports mal ausgerufen. Und in dieser Dekade sollten eben dann ganz viele sportliche Großereignisse stattfinden und mit so die größten davon waren die Olympischen Winterspiele 2014 in Sochi und natürlich die WM 2018. Da haben wir ja dann jeweils schon mal gesehen, wie sich zum einen Russland nach außen präsentiert und aber wie das ja auch sich dann intern auf die Strukturen der Zivilgesellschaft auswirkt. Hatte das denn dann auch positive Effekte, wenn wir jetzt mit diesen positiven Beispielen anfangen?
Ich weiß noch, 2014, da war ich bei den Paralympics als Journalist und in Russland wurden die olympischen Winterspiele gefeiert als großes Ereignis. Niemand hat darüber gesprochen, dass man den halben Kaukosus zerfranzt hat. Für Bobbahnen oder Hotels, die später keiner mehr brauchen wird, sind ja viele, viele Milliarden dafür draufgegangen. Nein, es war der Stolz Russlands, diese Spiele organisiert zu haben. Und dann waren die Paralympics und dann kam bald auch schon die Annektierung der Krim und das Vordringen von porussischen Separatisten in den Osten der Ukraine. Und einige Leute, das kann man nicht belegen, klar, aber die haben in Russland gesagt, dass vielleicht ohne dieses Rausch im Sport Putin gar nicht so eine breite Brust gehabt hätte für diesen damals durchaus waghalsigen Schritt, diese Krim zu annektieren. Mittlerweile gibt es da keine Kritik mehr aus dem Westen, das nimmt man so hin, aber damals war es so. Und dann gehen wir weiter. In Syrien mischen die Russen mit, dann gab es die Einmischung bei der US-Präsidentschaftswahl, die Konflikte in der Ukraine, die dauern immer noch an. Und der Sport gibt halt so eine Bühne, die ein bisschen Alltag intern erscheinen lässt und auch bei uns. Weil wenn wir Putin im Westen, das weiß Putin, das wissen viele Russen, dass viele Menschen im Westen, viele Medien Russland auf Putin reduzieren. Und wir kennen auch die ganzen Bilder, wo Putin eifach gespielt oder oberkörperfrei zeigt sich als Sportler. Die Männlichkeit ist ein wichtiges Thema, die man dort ausstellt. Umfragewerte, Putin hat lange immer noch sehr hohe Umfragewerte gehabt. Die gehen runter, aber die sind immer noch sehr hoch gewesen. Vielleicht auch wegen des Sports, weil es eines der weicheren Themen ist, über die man sich relativ unideologisch präsentieren kann.
Wie würdest du aus Sicht der Organisationen in Russland die Auswirkungen dieser Turniere bewerten? Vorher und nachher gab es Einschränkungen der Versammlungsfreiheit, es gab Festnahmen, also die Zahlen haben sich vorher und nachher nicht wirklich verändert, aber während der Turniere war es dann doch anders. Das war ja dann auch eine der Problematiken, das hatte ich hier im Rasenfunk auch sehr ausführlich thematisiert, weil wir schon, ich glaube, sieben Monate vor der WM monatlich mit Katrin Scheib in Moskau einfach nur über Dinge gesprochen haben, die mit der WM zu tun haben. Die Problematik für so außenstehende Berichterstatter wie uns war, wie will man das werten, dass auf der einen Seite es vorher große Einschränkungen gab, was Versammlungsfreiheit, Vorratsdatenspeicherung etc. angeht, dass man auch schon davon gehört hatte, dass es auch Ansagen an die russischen Hooligans gab, jetzt hier wird, das soll ein Fest der Freude werden, wir wollen keine negativen Schlagzeilen und die haben sich dann auch nach allem, was man weiß, eher so in den Untergrund zurückgezogen. Und gleichzeitig war damals ja schon zu erwarten, nach der WM wird sein, wie vor der WM. Es wird einfach wieder genauso sein. Und es gab ja dann auch relativ schnell Demonstrationen, bei denen dann wieder viele tausende Menschen auch zum Teil festgenommen wurden. Kann man dann trotzdem sagen, dass diese Entspannungsphase während der Turniere für etwas gut ist? Oder ist das dann eben Augenwischerei und man sollte auf diesen Trick, auf diesen optischen Trick nicht reinfallen?
Ja, das ist vielleicht eine der entscheidenden Fragen, auf die wir denn viel zu wenig noch schauen nach der WM. Ich habe die WM in St. Petersburg verbracht. Ich war beim Konfort Cup ein Jahr davor in Moskau. Und während der WM 2018 in St. Petersburg, da stand ich auch mit offenen Augen, habe gesehen, wie Fans aus Lateinamerika Alkohol getrunken haben auf den Straßen, einige haben gekifft und es war alles ganz locker und die Polizei hat zugeschaut. Es gab LGBTIQ-Fan und es gab auch kein Pride House, so durften sie sich nicht nennen, aber es gab Veranstaltungszentren, wo unterschiedliche Gruppen ihre Veranstaltungen gemacht haben. Es war schon sehr bunt und sehr vielfältig. Nach der WM war ich jetzt nicht mehr in Russland. Ich kann auch nur das lesen und sehen, was die Korrespondenten von dort berichten. Das spricht dafür, dass die Zivilgesellschaft weiterhin zurückgedrängt wird. Putin hat sich selbst die Verfassung ändern lassen, dass er bis er 150 Jahre alt ist Präsident bleiben. Darf. Generell würde ich immer sagen, auch das Sommermähchen im Positiven. Ein Fußballturnier von fünf Wochen kann keine Gesellschaft, kann keinen Staat grundlegend verändern. Vielleicht mal einen ganz kurzen Schwenk. Ich war für meinen Buch auch in Buenos Aires. Was mich interessiert hat, da kann man es ja mit ein bisschen mehr zeitlichem Abstand sehen. Die WM78 war Argentinien in einer Militärdiktatur, der mutmaßlich 30.000 Menschen zum Opfer gefallen sind. Argentinien hat die WM gewonnen. Ich habe die Leute auch gefragt, hat die Diktatur davon profitiert? Da haben mir verschiedene Leute gesagt, dass vielleicht im Rausch des Final-Siegels gegen die Niederlande, vielleicht noch zwei, drei Tage später, hätte der Diktator Videla vielleicht eine freie Wahl gewonnen. Aber schon in den Monaten danach war der Frust wieder da und war die Unzufriedenheit wieder da. Das ging nicht mehr so lange weiter. Argentinien hat den Falklandkrieg verloren und dann war es vorbei. Vielleicht sollten wir nicht ganz so sehr das Hochjatzen den Fußball. Das hat nicht so eine langfristigen Folgen. Es gibt sicherlich für beides auch Beispiele. Wenn man die Olympischen Spiele in Peking sieht, 2008, auch da mit Xi Jinping sind jetzt die Regeln, Presse, Justiz und so weiter, hat es noch verschärft. Aber ob man das jetzt in Relation zu den Olympischen Spielen legen kann, das weiß ich nicht und das ist auch nicht ausreichend erforscht.
Es ist insofern eine relevante Fragestellung, weil mir die Hauptargumentationslinie von Akteuren aus dem Fußball oder aus dem Sport generell zu sein scheint, dass man sagt, ja klar, spielen wir jetzt hier in Mordor, also ich überspitze jetzt ein bisschen, aber wir bringen ja unsere Regenbogen- Kapitänsbinden mit und wir helfen hier zehn Orks, dass sie nicht mehr so schlimm unterdrückt werden. Jetzt habe ich mich so ein bisschen drüber lustig gemacht, das wollte ich jetzt aber an der Stelle, also ich will das nicht kleinreden und gleichzeitig will ich es aber auch nicht überhöhen. Und ich habe das Gefühl, das ist so mit die Hauptrechtfertigung für eigentlich jegliche Kritik, die man an Ausrichterländern hat. Ich meine, mit der WM Katar laufen wir dann auf ein ganz anderes Kaliber zu und da haben wir das ja, dass Vertreter des FC Bayern ganz oft sagen, naja, gerade weil wir da hinfahren, können wir vor Ort Dinge verändern. Und jetzt sagst du aber, und das sagen ja auch Studien, naja, ehrlicherweise verändern diese Turniere erstmal gar nichts, außer dass manche Leute sehr viel Geld damit verdienen und aber der Gesamtheit der Menschen in der Regel Geld verloren geht.
Genau, und weil ich diese Diskussion schon bei so vielen Sportveranstaltungen vorab mitgemacht habe und sie ja auch mit Texten und Radiofeaturen ja auch begleitet habe und ich mich wundere, ob ich mich nicht ständig wiederhole, bloß die Ländernamen austausche und ich ja selbst dann auch danach nicht mehr dorthin reise, sondern mir dann das nächste Land vorn nehme. Ich gehöre ja quasi auch zu dieser Achterbahn. Deswegen wäre es gut, mal jetzt am Beispiel Katar das mal vielleicht zu verändern und nicht immer die große Frage nach dem Boykott zu stellen, der ohnehin nicht kommen wird, weil die deutsche Wirtschaft mit Katar verwachsen ist. 1,4 Milliarden Euro Exporte gehen von deutschen Unternehmen nach Katar. Katar ist an Volkswagen beteiligt, an der Deutschen Bank. Die Kanzlerin hat den Emir 2018 empfangen. Und außenpolitisch setzt man wesentlich mehr auf den stabilen Staat Katar als auf andere Regime, von denen man nicht weiß, ob sie bald noch existieren. Und auch dieses ganze neue Lieferkettengesetz, was jetzt erstmal ab einer Mitarbeiterzahl von 3.000 gelten soll, da ist der Fußball mit relativ kleinen Unternehmen der FC Bayern, ich glaube vielleicht hat er maximal 1.000 Mitarbeiter, aber hat natürlich von der Reichweite, wirkt er wie ein Konzern. Und der FC Bayern kann natürlich nicht katterdemokratisieren, aber natürlich sollten sich die Funktionäre auch nicht so naiv äußern. Aber was geht, worauf man vielleicht die Clubs, die FIFA und so weiter festnageln kann, ist Menschenrechtskonzepte, auch nach Trainingslagern, nach einer WM, da weiter hinzugehen, Verträge zu schließen, zu schauen, mit welchen Partnern und Subunternehmen arbeitet man. Das ginge alles, die eigenen Mitarbeiter, die eigenen Sponsoren einzubeziehen, also kleinteiliger vielleicht zu denken und vielleicht nicht allzu viel zu wollen. Und das könnte vielleicht ein nächster Schritt sein. Aber der Fußball mit seiner Emotionalität, mit seiner Doppelpasskultur, ich meine die Fernsehsendung, also entweder alles muss immer so empört sein und man will die endgültigen Antworten. Wir haben jetzt doch daraus gelernt, dass ein Fußballturnier jetzt nicht grundlegend ein Land verändert. Im Gegenteil sogar. Aber ich glaube, das ist auch so. Also die FIFA, das sagt sie zumindest, will bei künftigen Bewerbungsverfahren die Menschenrechte konkrete abfragen. Und ja, natürlich, das kann man skeptisch sehen und so weiter.
Ja, ich stelle mir da halt die Frage, ob da eine Balance besteht zwischen Nutzen und Aufwand für die Betreiberländer. Und auf der einen Seite, wenn wir jetzt dann wieder von Katar zu Russland zurückkommen, kann man sich jetzt eben einfach präsentieren. Und letztlich ist St. Petersburg trotz dieser Kass-Sperre zur zweitwichtigsten Spielstätte des Turniers geworden. Denn nachdem Dublin als Ausrichter gestrichen wurde, weil es da keine Garantien für Zuschauer im Stadion gab, kamen die dort für dort vorgesehenen Gruppenspiele noch mal zusätzlich zu St. Petersburg. Also da wird es noch mehr Möglichkeiten geben, sich zu präsentieren. Und jetzt haben wir dann eben auf der einen Seite wieder ein sehr wichtiges Ereignis. Die Augen der Welt, das ist so ein bisschen ein angeschmachtetes Bild, aber es stimmt dann vielleicht im Fall einer EM ein bisschen mehr dann doch. Die richten sich nach St. Petersburg und dort kann sich Russland eben als weltoffen zeigen, als freundlich, als sauber, als toll organisiert, als schillernd, als glänzend. Und steht das, diese Plattform, die man dann eben einem Staat bietet, denn wirklich in der Relation zu diesen kleinteiligen Dingen, die du jetzt angesprochen hast, die dann aber auch über Jahre hinweg im Nachgang verändert werden könnten?
Ja, was wäre die Alternative? Also ich sage immer, manchmal halb zynisch gemeint, halb ernst. Man könnte sich ein komplett neues Hobby suchen. Man könnte keine Trikots mehr kaufen, die in asiatischen, niedrigen Ländern gebastelt wurden. Man könnte kein PayTV-Abo mehr abschließen, was natürlich auch von solchen Partnern, Konzernen abhängig ist. Der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk, ARD und ZDF, die zahlen viel Geld um überhaupt von einer EM und von einer FIFA WM, wie sie offiziell heißt, berichten zu dürfen. Jeder hat seine eigene Möglichkeit. Leute sagen immer, das ist eine ganz beliebte Frage, soll man denn die WM nicht mehr in diesen Ländern stattfinden lassen? So muss man sich mal die Entscheidungsgremien von FIFA, IOC und so weiter anschauen. Da sitzen leider nicht nur Schweizer und Skandinavier und Australier, sondern da sitzen natürlich auch Menschen aus Autokratien, aus nicht-demokratischen Ländern. Und im Fußball ist es so, dass kleinere Länder das gleiche Stimmrecht haben wie der DFB oder die britische FA. Es ist auch interessant, die Gastrom-Spots bei der Champions League, da sieht man einen Dirigent, und das ist Valery Gergiev. Das ist nicht nur der Chef des Marinsgithäartest in St. Petersburg, das ist ein Putin-Buddy, aber er ist auch der Chefdirigent der Münchner Philharmoniker eines von der Kommune finanzierten Orchesters. Ich glaube, das ist einer der besten bezahlten Mitarbeiter der Stadt München. Am Anfang gab es da einen kleinen Shitstorm in München, außerhalb von Bayern schon nicht mehr. Aber das ist normal, dass Valery Gergiev in der Hochkultur, der hat auch einen Palmyra in Syrien dirigiert, nachdem Russland mitgewirkt hat im Krieg. Auf der einen Seite ist es gut, dass wir im Fußball wesentlich mehr darüber sprechen als woanders, aber das ist eine Frage. Hat es bei dir auch gerade geklingelt?
Und gleichzeitig habe ich immer ein gewisses Unwohlsein dabei, weil ich dann auch manchmal das Gefühl habe, ich versuche für eine klare Haltung zu stehen, oder ich habe auch eine klare Haltung, und dazu gehört eben, dass ich Diskriminierung in jedweder Form Scheiße finde und das nicht möchte, und dass ich finde, dass jeder jedem leben darf, wie er möchte und so weiter und so fort, dass Frauen dieselben Rechte haben sollten wie Männer und so weiter. Und gleichzeitig habe ich manchmal aber auch das Gefühl, auf einem hohen Rost zu sitzen, wenn ich dann über andere Länder spreche, in denen das nicht so ist, weil ich ja eigentlich auch nicht erwarten können kann, dass die ganze Welt nach meinen Vorstellungen funktioniert. Andererseits weiß ich aber, dass es dort Menschen gibt, Minderheiten, die darunter sehr sehr leiden. Und für die ist es dann ja dann doch wichtig, sich zu äußern, zumindest wenn man möchte, dass es denen nicht mehr so geht. Ich weiß nicht, ob mein Punkt jetzt klar wird, aber ich habe manchmal so ein bisschen, das wird sich jetzt wahrscheinlich auch durch diese ganze Sendung ziehen. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, ich zeige jetzt mit dem Finger auf andere, obwohl ich ja auch wirklich nicht jedem vorschreiben kann, jedem Land zum Beispiel, wie es strukturiert ist. Wie gehst du denn mit dieser Problematik um?
Aber du bist eigentlich, finde ich, das ist ein gutes Beispiel, wie man es machen kann, weil du sprichst ja natürlich auch über die Emotionen, über den Spaß, über das Technische, über das Angenehme des Fußballs. Und gleichzeitig bringst du immer wieder auch kritische Themen, da ist Humor dabei. Also so könnte ja eine differenzierte Plattform über den Fußball aussehen, die weder nur negativ ist, als auch nur verklärend und romantisierend. So kann es ja auch sein, damit erreichst du ja auch viele Menschen. Und das ist ein guter Punkt, den du ansprichst mit der Bevormundung. Auch das war in Russland so, dass ich dort Aktivistinnen getroffen habe, die fühlen sich von diesem Ton der Menschenrechtsorganisation, von einigen Menschenrechtsorganisationen, die fühlen sich da zurechtgewiesen. Und die haben natürlich immer auch öfter die Wahrnehmung, da sind wieder die westlichen Medien, sprechen mit ihrer oberlehrerhaften, gönnerhaften Attitüde. Und der Ton macht die Musik, würde ich sagen. Also, dass man auf Augenhöhe spricht, auch dass man, wie gesagt, die Regime nicht gleich setzt mit den Menschen, die dort leben. In Russland sind immer noch viele kreative Leute, die sich da engagieren. Man kann einfach auch zuhören. Und das ist auch ganz, ganz wichtig, wenn wir uns in unseren Formaten ischofieren, uns aufregen, unseren Frust ablassen. Wen erreicht das letztendlich? Da gibt es auch schon Berichte, dass Putin, das gilt auch für andere Autokraten, je öfter er von westlichen Staatschefs gemaßregelt wird, an wem lässt er denn den Frust innen aus? Das macht er wahrscheinlich an den ohnehin marginalisierten Leuten, dass er den Frust dort rauslässt. Oder dann mal auch zum Beispiel, sehr interessant auch in anderen Ländern, wenn sobald sich deutsche Parteien oder deutsche Politiker kritisch äußern, dann kriegen das oftmals die deutschen Organisationen in den jeweiligen Ländern zu spüren, die da an der Zivilgesellschaft mitwirken. Das ist ganz normal Diplomatie. Da gibt es viele kluge Menschen, viele ganz ausgefeilte, langfristig über Jahre angelegte Konzepte. Und das fehlt mir im Fußball so ein bisschen, dass wir immer in diesen kurzen Schritten denken und glauben, jetzt haben wir ein paar Jahre bis Katar, ein paar Jahre bis Russland, und da können wir ganz viel machen und danach ist wieder alles vorbei. Aber da gibt es schon ganz viele Profis, und da gibt es ganz viele Organisationen und Menschenrechtskonzepte. Deswegen würde ich die Diskussion immer, oder das ist nicht unsere Aufgabe, das ist die Aufgabe von den Clubs und von den Verbänden, das kleinteiliger, zielgerichteter machen. Und dass die FIFA, dass die UEFA auch ihre Macht ausspielen. Wenn jemand wie Aserbaidschan so ein Turnier haben möchte, dann muss er eben auch gewisse Standards erfüllen. Aber oftmals ist das Gegenteil der Fall, weil man Geld von Gazprom möchte, weil man Geld von Soka wollte. Das ist also eine Firma aus Aserbaidschan. Es ist ja leider andersrum der Fall meistens.
Und wenn wir dann kurz auf Sankt Petersburg als Ausrichter zurückkommen, also wir werden die erwartbaren Bilder sehen, wir werden Fans im Stadion haben, wir werden Vladimir Putin sehen, wie er zwischen wichtigen Menschen sitzt und selbst ja auch kein unwichtiger Mensch ist. Wie würdest du das denn jetzt dann einordnen in diesem größeren Kontext? Weil du ja im Grunde jetzt selber ja auch schon jetzt auch mehrfach gesagt hast, wir reden jetzt hier ja auch nur über ein Fußballturnier und wir wollen es jetzt auch nicht zu sehr hochjassen. Wie glaubst du, sollte man das jetzt dann einordnen?
Na das, manchmal denke ich mir auch, Vladimir Putin, der ist jetzt auch weit über 60 und der ist jetzt so lange dabei. Ich glaube, das ist ihm mittlerweile vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr so wichtig, dass er die x-te Sportveranstaltung hat. Und der sitzt jetzt fest im Sattel und muss jetzt seine Nachfolge regeln. Aber ja, das ist ein Element. Und deswegen wundere ich mich halt über dieses Hamsterrad, das wir dann oftmals die gleichen Fragen stellen. Und vielleicht, und da werde ich manchmal, haben wir da auch kontroverse Debatten innerhalb der Kolleginnen- schaft im Journalismus, ist vielleicht ein Miteinanderreden auch gar nicht mehr so schlecht. Also Putin war ja auch mal anders. Er hat auch schon mal am Bundestag gesprochen. Und Wanne durch Annäherung, Willy Brandt, war nicht so schlecht in den 70er Jahren. Klar, ganz andere Zeiten. Aber ohne Russland scheint es irgendwie auch nicht zu gehen. Das sieht man bei Belarus, das sieht man bei Syrien, das sieht man bei ganz anderen Ländern. Und auch kleinere Länder wenden sich dann eben auch zu Russland zu oder auch zu China. Da ist viel Geld vorhanden. Und die Europäische Union, wenn sie überhaupt eine Macht haben will, außenpolitisch zwischen China, zwischen den USA, dann macht es vielleicht auch mal Sinn, mit anderen Leuten wieder auch zu sprechen und sich nicht immer auf den heeren Werten auszuruhen, die man in Europa hat, während man gleichzeitig flüchtende Menschen aus Nordafrika ertrinken lässt und andere Sachen sich auch leistet. Gut, das ist jetzt Halbwissen an diesen außenpolitischen Fragen, aber ich würde sagen, vielleicht ist ja auch mal der Fußball, der Sport, wenn andere Sachen nicht funktioniert haben, auch eine Gelegenheit, wieder ein bisschen miteinander zu reden. Ich kann aber auch nicht garantieren, dass es danach besser wird.
Das ist der Blick von Russland quasi nach außen oder von außen auf Russland. Und dann, finde ich, gibt es ja noch eine zweite Ebene, und die findet in deinem Buch ja auch statt, was ich eben so extrem spannend daran finde, weil die ist so ein bisschen unterbeleuchtet in vielen anderen Publikationen. Und zwar die Innenperspektive, wo man ja auch sagen kann, wenn wir uns mal kurz von der egozentrischen Sichtweise, wie finden wir eigentlich Russland und Vladimir Putin lösen, dann glaube ich manchmal, dass wir das vielleicht auch überschätzen, wie wichtig das eigentlich diesen Autokraten ist, nach außen zu schildern. Und wie wir damit unterschätzen, wie wichtig es ist intern, diese Sportereignisse zu nutzen. Du hattest es ja vorhin schon als Kit der Gesellschaft beschrieben. Und da kann man ja nicht nur jetzt über den Fußball sprechen und über das, was bei der WM 2018 dann in Russland passiert ist, auch im Guten für die Regionen und auch vielleicht auch so ein bisschen fürs Gemeinschaftsgefühl, sondern da fallen mir zum Beispiel auch diese Russland-Spiele ein, die ich glaube, nach Olympia, während Olympia, als die Sperre eingesetzt hat und einige Olympioniken nicht teilnehmen durften und andere unter einer IOC-Flagge, die dann doch sehr russisch aussah, um es jetzt mal so zu sagen. Da hat ja Vladimir Putin intern im Land seine eigenen Spiele veranstaltet, wo die auch ähnlich hohe Prämien gewonnen haben, wie wenn sie eine Goldmedaille geholt hätten bei olympischen Spielen. Und allein das zeigt ja schon, wie wichtig vielleicht der Sport, dass der vielleicht nach innen viel wichtiger ist als nach außen. Und wir das dann vielleicht überschätzen, weil wir halt diejenigen sind, die außen stehen.
Das ist so, das ist so. Also ich habe dann auch, wir sollten nicht immer denken, dass die Leute nur an unserer Wahrnehmung interessiert sind. Gerade in so einem Land wie Russland, wo der Fußball auch seit weit mehr als 100 Jahren ganz eng an Geschichte und Politik gekoppelt war. Von der russischen Revolution über Stalin, aber klar kalter Krieg, als der Sport ganz wichtig war, Medaillen zu generieren. Der Boykott von Moskau, dann später in Los Angeles, da war der Sport natürlich im Ostblock und vor allem in der Sowjetunion ganz, ganz wichtig. Und auf eine andere Art ist er das jetzt auch noch. In den russischen Regionen, da kann man auch von Verein zu Verein gehen. Ich habe zuerst Tschechenien angesprochen, also die Teilrepublik, wo es ganz viel Ärger früher gab, in Anführungsstrichen, das ist eigentlich noch ein verharmlosenes Wort mit islamistischem Terror, und Ramsan Kadirov, dessen Vater ja getötet wurde im Stadion, Ramsan Kadirov, der sozusagen der Stadthalter, der Putin in Tschechienien, in Grozny den Rücken frei hält. Und das macht er eben auch mit dieser Übermaskulin, mit dieser Kultur. Und er lädt einen Spieler wie Ronaldinho ein oder Maradona, auch Popstars. Und weil Fußball, als die WM 2018 war, da hat das ägyptische Team mit Mo Salah, mit dem Star des FC Liverpool, in Tschechienien Station gemacht. Und plötzlich kam dann Ramsan Kadirov morgens auf den Trainingsplatz und ist im Cabrio mit Mo Salah durch die Gegend gefahren. Und Salah wusste gar nicht, wie ihm geschieht, wurde zum Ehrenbürger ernannt, soll sich später auch beschwert haben darüber, dass er so vereinnahmt wurde. Aber das zieht, ja. Also Kadirov fährt ab und zu mal nach Moskau zur Audienz von Putin, wollte auch einmal schon zurücktreten, ja, offiziell. Putin hat ihn nicht gelassen. Und so kann man auch bei anderen, also so ein riesiges Land, das regiert sich ja nicht nur mit einem starken Mann. Man denkt immer, das wird alles aus Moskau gemacht, aber die Regionen sind so weit von Moskau entfernt. Und noch einmal, auch wenn wir über Fußball sprechen, man darf nicht denken, dass der Fußballer jetzt das Entscheidende ist. Aber es ist eben ein Element, über das die Leute sprechen, wo es Gesprächskanäle gibt, wo auch mal Gelder fließen, wo man sich im Stadion trifft. Das ist ganz, ganz wichtig. So eine Ehrentribüne, wo man sich gegenseitig schmeicheln kann, wo man lockerer ist, wo die Gesprächsatmosphäre vielleicht ein bisschen weicher ist. Das ist in Russland, aber es ist auch in vielen anderen Ländern der Welt so.
Das hast du alles auch sehr genau im Machtspieler noch beschrieben. Das ist der eine Ausrichter dieser EM, der man unter diesem Aspekt der Fußball als politischen Instrument blicken kann. Wir haben noch einen weiteren mit der Türkei, bei dem eine Komponente mit dazu kommt, die interessanterweise auch in Russland eine größer werdende Rolle spielt. Das habe ich zuerst bei dir gelesen, nämlich den Einfluss der Religion. In Russland ist es dann die Russisch-Orthodoxe Kirche. Bei Erdogan und der Türkei gestaltet sich das ein bisschen anders. Wie würdest du denn sagen, unterscheidet sich jetzt, wenn wir diesen Russland-Komplex, das haben wir jetzt ja sehr ausführlich besprochen, wie Putin den Sport für sich nutzt, wie unterscheidet er sich denn da von Erdogan oder Erdogan sich von Putin besser gesagt?
Erdogan war der bessere Fußballer. Da sieht man ja immer noch viele Bilder, sieht man ja, wie er gekickt hat. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das eine Legende ist, aber dass sein Spitzname Imam Beckenbauer war, dass er angeblich von der Profikarriere stand. Das kommt eigentlich in jedem Artikel darüber vor. Erdogan soll ein passabler Fußballer gewesen sein. Natürlich, da kann man weit in die Geschichte zurückgehen. Da gibt es auch interessante Bücher darüber, dass auch schon mit der Gründung der modernen Türkei und der Mustafa Kemal, der genannt Atatürk, dass da auch der Fußball wie so oft in den islamisch geprägten Ländern am Anfang Skepsis entgegengeschlagen ist, aber dann doch er sich relativ schnell verbreitet hat. Und wichtig war als Vernetzung, als gute Laune-Tour auch für Leute, für unterschiedliche Strömungen. Und in der jüngeren Vergangenheit ist es so, dass die Türkei ja auch mal eine EM alleine ausrichten wollte, zuletzt halt 2024. Das Turnier wird jetzt in Deutschland stattfinden. Aber wäre sie in der Türkei, hätte sie in der Türkei stattgefunden, 24, dann wären einige Spielorte vor allem so in Städten gewesen, in Stadien gewesen, die eher einen höheren Wahlanteil bei der AKP haben, also bei Erdogans Partei. Und das ist auch ein Trend. Patrick Hedy, das ist ein Journalist, der hat ein Buch darüber geschrieben und hat das sehr detailliert nachgewiesen. Das ist dieses Patronagen-Netzwerk um Erdogan. Man verteilt Bauaufträge. Und als die Wirtschaft noch geboomt hat in der Türkei, unterschiedliche Unternehmen, das früher war die Wirtschaftselite, hat sich ganz stark diesen säkularen Werten von Atatürk verschrieben, wo Staat und Religion getrennt waren. Aber immer mehr dann doch eher konservativere Leute. Und natürlich sehr, sehr viel Geld für Flughäfen, für Moscheen, für Religionsschulen, für Shopping-Malls draufgegangen. Aber eben auch für mehr als 30 Stadien, die entstanden sind. Teilweise eben auch in Konya oder in Trabzon, also eher in konservativeren Städten. Und bei uns ist wahrscheinlich Besiktas Istanbul bekannt, mit seiner sehr kritischen linken Fanszene, die demonstriert haben gegen Erdogan. Und Besiktas, ich war da auch, da sieht man ganz viele Atatürk-Bilder und Symboliken von Atatürk, also der Überfigur der Türkei. Und dieses Stadion von Besiktas, was neu gebaut wurde, früher hieß das nach einem Weggefährten von Atatürk, einer Mitstreiter, wie viele Stadien nach ihm oder seinen Freunden benannt wurden. Aber das scheint auch Erdogan zurückdrehen zu wollen. Er lehnt sich wieder an diese alte, osmanische Kultur ein, die große Zeit der Osmanen und als man ein Weltreich war. Auch die Fußballfans haben ganz genaue Schlachten im Gedächtnis. Das Schade von Besiktas ist jetzt in einem Mobilfunkunternehmen benannt und nicht mehr nach historischen Figuren. Das sind einige Beispiele wie die Türkei, wo der Fußball vielleicht diese zunehmende Religiosität auch als Beispiel verdeutlicht.
Dafür gibt es jetzt ein Stadion, was nach Recep Erdogan selbst benannt wurde. Die religiöse Komponente kommt damit dazu. Du hast ja jetzt schon ein paar so Rahmendaten genannt. Allein diese 30 Fußballstadien, die gebaut wurden, an denen bin ich immer wieder hingeblieben, wenn ich Texte dazu gelesen habe, jetzt in der Vorbereitung dazu. Weil das einfach so eine irre Zahl ist. Und gleichzeitig war das ja auch, finde ich, wenn man sich mit dem türkischen Fußball und zum Beispiel den Länderspielorten auseinandergesetzt hat, dann ist das aufgefallen, dass irgendwann Istanbul nicht mehr so wichtig war, sondern eben andere Regionen. Und dann habe ich bei dir gelernt, okay, das sind eben Regionen, in denen nicht nur die Regierungspartei AKP hohe Stimmenanteile hat, sondern eben auch dieses Patronagentum und auch dieses religiös mit dem Staat verwobene, anscheinend einfacher durchzusetzen ist als in Istanbul selbst, was eben an sich ja schon eigentlich keine einzelne Stadt ist, sondern als viele einzelne Regionen fast schon bezeichnet werden muss, ohne dass ich da selber im Detail schon tief genug drin wäre. Jetzt haben wir in der Türkei aber auch den Sonderfall, dass sich Politik und Fußball auch schon mal in einer sehr, sehr plakativen Art und Weise verwoben haben, nämlich dass Fans mit Teil waren der Kundgebung im Gezi-Park und dann auf dem Taxi-Platz, wo sich dann auch hunderte Fans von eigentlich rivalisierenden Vereinen von Besiktas, Fener und Galatasaray miteinander verbündet haben im gemeinsamen Protest und die das dann aber im Nachhinein auch zu spüren bekommen haben. Wie hat sich da Erdogan gegenüber den Fußballfans verhalten?
Ja, das ist, finde ich, noch immer so eine unterschätzte Komponente, die Mobilisierungskraft der Fußballfans, der Ultras, die ja im Straßenkampf ja geschult sind, die sich vernetzen können, die wissen können, wie sie schnell mobilisieren können, Demonstrationen auf die Beine stellen können, Barrikaden errichten können, das hat man in der Ukraine gesehen, das hat man beim Arabischen Frühling in vielen Ländern Nordafrikas gesehen, das hat man in diesem Jahr gerade aktuell auch in Kolumbien gesehen oder in den vergangenen ein, zwei Jahren auch in Chile, wo Fußballfans sich vernetzen und aus unterschiedlichen Gründen gegen ihre Regierung protestieren. Und in der Türkei war vielleicht eines der ersten prominenten Beispiele, was wirklich danach auch, und das ist vielleicht ein Problem, stark glorifiziert wird. Da entstehen dann Dokumentationen, da entstehen Plakate, da entsteht so ein Heldenkult. Und wir schauen eigentlich danach nicht mehr so richtig hin, was denn daraus geworden ist. In Ägypten zum Beispiel die Ultras aus Kairo, die als Terroristen jetzt gelten. Viele von ihnen sind getötet worden, sind im Gefängnis, werden, werden, also Limelmey Seale, also in Kairo, diese wogende Fankultur von früher, das gibt es eigentlich nicht mehr. Die werden kleingehalten. In der Türkei ist es nicht ganz so krass, aber auch dort mit anderen Mitteln wird ein Ticketsystem eingeführt, wo man seine Daten hinterlassen muss. Fans haben keine Lust mehr, auch ziehen weg und man kann nicht mehr die Banner oder die Gesänge ins Stadion bringen, weil nach dem Putsch dann auch gegen Erdogan auch andere Gesetze und Regeln eingeführt wurden. Also das ist jetzt nicht mehr so wie früher. Das findet vielleicht auch woanders statt. Und es ist auch wichtig zu betonen, der Protest von Fußballfans ist nicht nur im Stadion der Fall, sondern auch in sozialen Medien, in Kneipen, in der Diaspora. Also Menschen aus unterschiedlichen Milieus lernen sich ja wegen des Fußballs kennen, die sie sonst vielleicht nicht kennengelernt haben. Und das ist, finde ich, eine stark politische Komponente. Und die ist in Türkei anders als in Ägypten oder in Chile. Aber die Mobilisierungskraft der Ultras, einer jungen politischen Subkultur, das lohnt sich wirklich weiter zu erforschen. Und das ist in der Türkei im positiven und im negativen ein eindringliches Beispiel.
Ja, und gleichzeitig ist es auch ganz offensichtlich dem Staat, wenn ich einfach jetzt mal von dem Staat sprechen darf, bewusst, weil es ja dann den Vorfall gab, dass Fans von Besiktas bei einem Derby den Rasen gestürmt haben. Das Spiel wurde abgebrochen, der Verein bestraft. Und später wurde dann bekannt, dass diejenigen, die da gestürmt haben, Verbindungen zur Regierung haben und vielleicht gar nicht jetzt aus dem wirklichen Kern der Fans-Szene von Besiktas kamen. Also da würde ich ja schon fast von der Unterwanderung der Fan-Kultur sprechen, mit dem Zweck, sie zu diskreditieren. Und ja, in dem Fall wurden dann sogar auch Fans vor Gericht gestellt, allerdings alle Vorwürfe dann fallen gelassen.
Das ist interessant, nach solchen Protesten auch in anderen Ländern, lange gelten Ultras für Regierung als Halbstarke, die keine Ahnung haben, die sich da ein bisschen austoben. Aber wenn man dann sieht, was sie für Power entfalten können, dann gelten sie dann plötzlich eben doch als Gefahr für die nationale Sicherheit. Dann kommt die Power des Staates mit dem Geheimdienst, mit der Polizei, mit Einschüchterungsversuchen. Und dann, ja, es gab auch Beispiele aus anderen Ländern, wo dann gezielt solche Gruppen unterwandert werden. Wenn Ultras so einen Heldenstatus einnehmen und in die Popkultur eindringen, dann ist ja klar, dass sie auch neue Mitglieder gewinnen, dass sie auch großes Interesse wecken. Und dadurch wird so eine Gruppe immer wieder auch mal vermischt und dadurch entsteht eine neue Dynamik. Da ist eine sehr, sehr hohe Fluktuation. Das ist auch in Deutschland so, auch in anderen Ländern so. Das ist kein homogener Block und so ist es auch in der Türkei so. Die Menschen, oder es sind ja meistens junge Männer, wachsen irgendwann da auch raus. Und das ist, finde ich, das diskutieren wir auch zu selten. Das sind junge Männer, die im Fußball gewisse Eigenschaften erlernen, die sie dann mitnehmen. Die sie mitnehmen vielleicht in ihren Job, in ihrer, es gibt ja in der Türkei jetzt nicht so viele kritische Parteien, aber das ist eine Wechselwirkung. Fußballfans sind nicht nur Fußballfans, das sind Bürger, das sind Studierende, das sind Arbeiter. Und man kann im Fußball eben auch einiges mitnehmen. Und wenn es nur Mut und Zuversicht ist, das ist da gar nicht so wenig in autokratischen Regimen.
Die Türkei fällt jetzt hier vielleicht ein bisschen raus aus den Ländern, die wir besprechen. Mag vielleicht den ein oder anderen und die ein oder andere schon gewundert haben, denn die Türkei ist ja gar kein Ausrichterland bei dieser Europameisterschaft. Ich kam trotzdem irgendwie nicht an der Türkei vorbei, weil ich so drei Schnittmengen oder Ansatzpunkte sehe, die finde ich auch jetzt ins Hier und Jetzt und auch in diese EM ein bisschen hineinreichen. Das eine ist, das hast du schon kurz angesprochen, eben die wiederholt erfolglose Bewerbung der Türkei um eine Europameisterschaftsaustragung. Letztlich ist man jetzt dann auch für 20, 24 Jahre Deutschland unterlegen. Wie würdest du denn das bewerten bei allem, was wir so wissen, über die Art und Weise, wie diese Turniere vergeben werden, und dass es da jetzt nicht immer nach Fußballbegeisterung oder nach Fußballkultur in den Ländern geht, sondern auch wirtschaftliche und dann sicherlich auch politische Aspekte eine Rolle spielen. Wie würdest du das einordnen, dass die Türkei da jetzt schon mehrfach nicht zum Zug gekommen ist?
Mit den genauen Details, warum das so ist, es waren ja auch starke Bewerber früher. Ich glaube auch, dass früher oder später die Türkei diese Ein-Europameisterschaft auch mal austragen wird. Ich war in der Türkei, es ist natürlich ein tolles, spannendes Land, mit einer fantastischen Geschichte mit Kunst und Kultur. Ich fände es toll, wenn die EM mal in der Türkei wird. Ich würde lieber ein Spiel in Istanbul sehen, als jetzt zum 100. Mal in München. Das ist so mein privates Interesse. Natürlich würde man wieder aufschreien, klar, aus Menschenrechtsgesichtspunkten nicht, aber vielleicht werden wir uns ein bisschen davon lösen und sagen, die akzeptieren einfach mal die Wirklichkeit, dass das vernetzt ist und dass finanzielle Interessen bestehen, aber dass man trotzdem dort spielen kann, wenn man gewisse Regeln erwartet, wenn man Zugeständnisse erwartet, wenn man so viele Journalisten und so weiter mitbringt, Menschenrechtskonzepte. Vielleicht klinge ich da naiv, aber es wäre nicht schlecht. Und gerade wir hier in Deutschland, wo wir viele Menschen haben, mit einer türkischen Einwandere-Biografie, wäre das jetzt nicht so negativ. Also eine EM in der Türkei ist verständlicher als eine WM in Katar, die ein Land mit knapp über zwei Millionen Einwohnern. Aber früher oder später, so viele Interessenten hat die UEFA nicht mehr für dieses Turnier. Mit 24 Teams ist es ein relativ großes Starterfeld. Und nur in England, Frankreich oder Deutschland, das wäre dann irgendwann auch fad.
Und dann gibt es die zweite Schnittmenge zum deutschen Fußball, wo eben Politik und Fußball so eng aneinander haften und auch das zu Diskussionen geführt hat, dass ich das Gefühl hatte, auch wenn es jetzt primär nichts mit dieser Europameisterschaft zu tun hat, kann man es eigentlich kaum rauslassen aus dieser Sendung. Und zwar das Verhältnis von Fußballspielern wie Eker Gündoğan und Mesut Özi zu Erdogan persönlich. Und da gibt es ja auch noch andere, die man nennen könnte. Auch darüber schreibst du im Machtspieler und tust das auf eine differenziertere Art und Weise, als man es an manch anderer Stelle gelesen hat, weil du auch so ein bisschen die Perspektive der Sportler einnimmst. Und dann auch mit ganz guten Gegenbeispielen, unter anderem Hakan Şükür, also wer sich interessiert, wie es dem gerade geht, das mal googeln. Das ist wirklich, ja, da kann man sehen, wie es eben dann im Negativen laufen kann, wenn man sich zu Regime kritisch äußert oder zu Erdogan kritisch in dieser Stelle. So wäre es jetzt korrekt gewesen. Wie würdest du denn jetzt mit etwas Abstand das bewerten? Die Aufregung, die es damals gab vor der WM 2018, rund um das Foto von Erdogan und Özil und Erdogan und Gündogan und jetzt auch die weitere Entwicklung, die diese Beziehung eben zwischen Politiker auf der einen Seite, wenn auch ehemaliger Fußballspieler, und aktiver Profi auf der anderen Seite. Wie würdest du das sehen?
Ja, das ist auch eine Leitfrage. Was dürfen wir eigentlich von Fußballern, was dürfen wir von LeistungssportlerInnen verlangen, wenn sie einen Staat repräsentieren und dafür auch gutes Geld und Öffentlichkeit bekommen? Mesut Özil ist wirklich in alle Richtungen ein gutes Beispiel. Weil der hat ja nicht nur als junger Mann schon, ist er ja als Muslim, nach Mecca gepilgert, hat ein Foto davon gezeigt, das wurde positiv gesehen. Dann kam das Foto mit Erdogan, Shitstorm. Später hat er sich dann für die Uiguren ausgesprochen, also der verfolgte Minderheit in China. Er hat auch für Hongkong was gesagt. Jetzt hat er auch vor kurzem wieder, als der Gaza-Konflikt mit Israel hochgeschnellt ist, eskaliert ist, hat er mit Fenerbahce Istanbul, seinem Verein, ein T-Shirt getragen. Freies Palästina. Das sind alles streitbare Themen. Und von unterschiedlichen Milieus wurde er dafür kritisiert und gelobt. Also immer schwarz oder weiß. Natürlich könnten wir auch mal akzeptieren, wenn jemand nicht unserer Meinung ist. Und deswegen würde ich jetzt mit Abstand sagen, dass die Aufregung nach dem Erdogan-Foto vielleicht doch ein bisschen überzogen war. Und vielleicht sollten wir dahin kommen, dass man vielleicht eher auch an die jüngeren Spieler herangeht. In Sportinternaten, die informiert, denen das Gefühl gibt, dass Fußball doch nicht das Wichtigste ist. Und dass sie früh schon eine Meinung bilden können. Mit Anfang und Mitte 20, wenn alles auf sie einprasselt, kann man ja gar nicht böse sein, wenn sie sich gar nicht mehr äußern. Weil sie es ohnehin nicht allen recht machen können. Und ich finde, es ist oftmals scheinheilig, dass viele Medien verlangen, seid auch mal mündige Sportler, äußert euch zu den Problemen der Welt. Und wenn sie es dann tun, wird es auch aus allen Perspektiven zeredet und klein gemacht. Und Hakan Şükür ist ein gutes Beispiel, einer der Rekord-Nationalspieler in der Türkei, viele Tore gemacht und muss jetzt im Exil in den USA Taxi fahren. Und seine Besitztümer wurden irgendwie beschlagnahmt. Das ist ja auch ein Thema, die Familien leben doch in der Türkei. Und das können wir jetzt nur mutmaßen, was die Familien von Özil, Gündogan und so weiter da vielleicht auch befürchten müssen, wenn sie sich nicht auf die Seite von Erdogan stellen. Das sind die Mutmaßungen. Aber weil wir nur mutmaßen können, vielleicht sollten wir uns da alle vielleicht ein bisschen mehr zurückhalten.
Und dann gibt es eine dritte Schnittmenge zum aktuellen Turnier. Und die kann man auch über Mesut Özil erzählen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du seine Antrittspressekonferenz oder seine Vorstellung damals in der Türkei mitverfolgt hast. Das war ein einigermaßen bizarres Schauspiel. Und da wurde er am Ende auch jetzt nicht gebeten, sondern er hat es einfach getan. Er hat Grüße geschickt an die Soldaten, die in Bakarabakh unterwegs sind und für Aserbaidschan gegen Armenien vorgehen. Und mit Aserbaidschan wiederum sind wir jetzt wieder bei einem EM-Teilnehmer oder Standort gelandet, der eine wichtige Rolle spielt. Kannst du uns mal kurz aufdröseln, wie sind denn die Beziehungen zwischen der Türkei und Aserbaidschan und worum geht es dann da?
Ja, Türkei und Aserbaidschan sind eng verbunden. Das geht natürlich auf eine ganz lange Geschichte zurück, der turksprachigen Völker in Anführungsstrichen. Aserbaidschan natürlich auch in der Vergangenheit im Ostblock, aber jetzt ist das einigende Band die gemeinsame Religion. Und Erdogan hat auch Aserbaidschan unterstützt im wieder aufgeflammten Konflikt um die Region Bekara-Bach. Aserbaidschan und Armenien streiten sich seit langem um diese Region. Und in Aserbaidschan, auch das ist ein autokratisches, vielleicht sogar diktatorisch geführtes Land, Ilyam Aliyev, der Staatschef, der die Macht von seinem Vater übernommen hat, 2003, der über beachtliche Öl- und Gasvorkommen verfügt, der nach dem Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion das Land natürlich auch positionieren musste. Das geht nicht nur mit Gas, sondern das soll jetzt auch mit Tourismus funktionieren, weil das Land eben auch eine Wirtschaftskrise durchlebt. Und wie viele andere Staaten funktioniert das mit Veranstaltungen. Da kommen dann Kulturveranstaltungen, da wird auch kleinere Sportereignisse, dann aber auch größere Sportereignisse. Das Finale der Euroleague war da, die European Games waren da, auch islamische Sportspiele waren da, auch kleinere rhythmische Sportgymnastik war auch zu Gast. Und jetzt eben vier Spiele bei der EM in Baku in der Hauptstadt. Erdogan und Aliyev sind enge Vertraute, die türkische Mannschaft für zwei Spiele in der Vorrunde in Baku bestreiten. Da ging die UEFA also auf beide Länder zu, weil Aserbaidschan selbst nicht qualifiziert ist. Das ist sozusagen so ein indirektes Heimspiel, würde ich mal sagen. Ja, und da wird es wirklich klar. Weil Baku spielt, glaube ich, in den europäischen politischen Netzwerken keine große Rolle. Wobei, wenn ich das dazu sage, wirtschaftlich natürlich schon. Man erinnert sich nur an die Verbindung von einigen CDU-Politikern mit Aserbaidschan. Also die machen das schon klug, haben auch Kollegen, Journalisten aufgezeigt, dass da viel Geld ausgegeben wird für Anzeigen, für Werbesports, für positive Stimmung in Europa zu Aserbaidschan. Und wir machen jetzt mit als Fußball-Anhänger.
Ich finde, Aserbaidschan ist so ein bisschen, ich hoffe, dass ich da nicht auf so einen Aktualitätshype-Zug nur mit aufspringe, aber das brisanteste Beispiel von den Ländern, die wir hier besprechen, weil wir hier auch im Kontext des Sports schon gesehen haben, wie die Politik oder die politische Situation vor Ort verhindern und eingreifen kann. Also es will mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz in den Kopf, wie man es einfach akzeptiert, dass Hendrik Mkhitaryan als Kapitän des armenischen Fußball-Nationalteams und bei dem Konflikt rund um die Region Bergkarabach geht es um Armenien versus Aserbaidschan. Und da wurde ein Krieg geführt, der jetzt zwar beendet ist, aber er hat verzichtet, das Europa League-Finale in Baku zu bestreiten, aus Angst um seine Sicherheit. Und wie viel mehr rote Flagge muss es denn geben, dass ein Spieler sagt, ich fühle mich hier nicht sicher genug, um hier ein Finale, ein wichtiges Spiel in meiner Karriere zu bestreiten? Und im Grunde kann ihm ja auch keiner widersprechen. Es war jetzt nicht so, dass die Reaktionen waren, ach komm, da macht er ja aus einer Mücken-Elefanten so eine Direktion. Ja, stimmt, ist tatsächlich ein bisschen doof mit diesem Finale im Baku. Und jetzt, zwei Jahre später, und eigentlich wäre es ein Jahr später gewesen, die EM wurde ja verschoben aus anderen Gründen, finden dann eben EM-Spiele dort statt.
European Games 2015 war ein ähnlicher Fall. Da haben ja auch deutsche Sportler mitgemacht. Und nach langen Verhandlungen ist auch eine armenische Delegation dorthin gereist. Massive militärischer Schutz für die armenischen Sportler, also das sind wirklich die Erzfeinde schlechthin. Und jetzt auch wieder wurden ja auf beiden Seiten Menschenrechtsverletzungen oder Kriegsverbrechen auch dokumentiert bei dem jüngsten Konflikt 2020 zwischen Armenien und Azerbaijan. Und wenn man auch schaut, ja, Ilya Maliev hat sich vor kurzem noch in einem neuen Museum präsentiert, wo aufgereihte Helme von gefallenen armenischen Soldaten ausgestellt sind, wo die armenischen Feinde sozusagen sehr karikaturenhaft dargestellt werden, wo Kriegsgerät inszeniert wird. Das gibt es auch in anderen Ländern, aber jetzt besonders prominent in Azerbaijan. Und das scheint sich sicher zu fühlen. Kurz vor einer Euro, der will natürlich auch provozieren, vielleicht ein bisschen. Spannend ist auch, dass der erfolgreichste Verein Aserbaidschans kulturelle Wurzeln in der Region Bekarabakh hat. In der Stadt Akdam, Anfang der 90er Jahre, nach dem Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion, als es wieder ausbrach, der Krieg und die Stadt Akdam damals zerstört wurde, sind die Fußballer von dort nach Baku geflohen. Der Verein Karabakh hat jetzt einige Meisterschaften hintereinander gewonnen, spielt auch hin und wieder in europäischen Wettbewerben, wird auch überdurchschnittlich unterstützt, weil er eben das Symbole ist für Phoenix aus der Asche, aus der Kriegsregion ist er entstanden. Der Pressesprecher von Karabakh hat vor kurzem auch bei Facebook geschrieben, sinngemäß, wir müssen ausnahmslos alle Armenier töten, wurde dafür auch lebenslang gesperrt. Also auch ganz andere auf beiden Seiten, aber besonders in Aserbaidschan, viele Spieler haben in sozialen Medien salutiert für die Armee, für das Militär, Opfer wurden gedacht, Tribünen wurden mit aserbaidschanischen Flaggen überspannt. Also die Symbolik ganz klar im Fußball breit ausgestellt.
Aber warum finden dann dort EM-Spiele statt? Wie ist das zu begründen?
Die Entscheidung ist ja sicherlich vorhergefallen. Und letztendlich ist das bei uns auch gar nicht so groß diskutiert worden. Klar, der Konflikt bei Karabach, den haben viele letztes Jahr zum ersten Mal überhaupt davon gehört. Das hat erst mal ein bisschen gedauert, das zu verstehen von zwei Ländern, die jetzt aus unserer Sicht in der Peripherie liegen. Und dann wird natürlich immer gesagt, soll da EM stattfinden? Aber mit den genauen Hintergründen, die habe ich jetzt gar nicht so intensiv wahrgenommen. Und ja, dann, wie würde es theoretisch dann laufen? Wer würde protestieren? Dann kann der DFB was sagen als größter Sportfachverband. Dann könnte auch vielleicht die FA was sagen in England. Die hat auch Einfluss. Dann könnte der FC Bayern was sagen oder die großen Clubs. Habe ich alles nicht gehört. Und wir beide oder auch das beachtliche Publikum, was wir jetzt haben, oder auch andere, das wird nicht reichen leider. Deswegen müssen wir vielleicht da Mehrheiten für unsere Themen gewinnen. Und ich stelle mir die Frage auch immer, aber ich wüsste nicht, wer sie irgendwie überhaupt aufwerfen sollen würde. Es gibt keine oder es gibt nicht ausreichende, wie soll ich sagen, Klauseln in diesen Ausrichtervertregen, die besagen, so, wenn ihr jetzt im nächsten Krieg beginnt, dann bekommt ihr die Spiele entzogen. Ich glaube nicht, dass das in dem Ausrichtervertrag steht.
Ganz so habe ich es jetzt gar nicht gemeint. Das ist quasi dann schon die Frage, warum es jetzt dann darum kein großes Aufhebenskipp, zumindest jetzt meiner Beobachtung nach, sondern die Frage, meinte ich eigentlich dahingehend, ist es jetzt wieder mit, in Anführungszeichen, nur mit Geld zu begründen, dass die UEFA dann Baku als Sportstandort wahr ernst nimmt. Das ist ja nicht nur der Fußball, sondern auch die Formel 1 ist ja unter anderem vor Ort da. Du hast vorhin schon Soccer angesprochen, den Energiekonzern, den niemand kannte. Und auf einmal war er UEFA-Sponsor. Und wer ihn gegoogelt hat oder Ecosiat hat, hat dann herausgefunden, aha, okay, da führen die Wege nach Aserbaidschan. Also ist die Wahrheit dann so einfach, dass man sagen muss, naja, die haben halt sehr, sehr viel Geld. Und deshalb sind sie dann interessant auch für einen Sportverband. Weil ansonsten gibt es ja, anders als zum Beispiel bei Russland, sehr wenig Gründe, die dafür sprechen, irgendein Event in Aserbaidschan stattfinden zu lassen.
Ja, also das Geld ist natürlich ein Grund, auch die Vernetzung, neue Märkte zu erschließen. Und was ich auch erst mal lernen musste, dass es glaube ich wirklich parallel Universen sind. Die Debatten, die wir jetzt vielleicht führen, oder auch in einigen Medien Westeuropas, ja schon gar nicht mehr in Ungarn oder in Tschechien oder in Baltikum, sondern in Deutschland, in Großbritannien, in Frankreich, vielleicht noch in Spanien. Die Debatten, die da, oder auch in Skandinavien, die dort geführt werden, ich glaube, die erreichen manchmal gar nicht die Gremien. Vielleicht noch den Präsidenten, Cheferin, der interviewt das regelmäßig, aber die Leute im UEFA-Exekutivkomitee, oder die sagen, gehen wir noch weiter, die FIFA, ich weiß nicht, ob die jetzt die Artikel im Guardian lesen, wenn sie von 5 Sterne zu Hotel zu 5 Sterne Hotel fahren, sich unabhängig fühlen, sich reich fühlen, jahrelang mit Korruption durchgekommen sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob das die nicht eher sogar langweilt. Das ist eine bittere Erkenntnis eigentlich, dass wir uns hier abstampeln können, informieren können. Und letztendlich, klar, unsere Bubble wird größer, die kritische Bubble wird größer, aber es ist immer noch eine Bubble, gemessen daran, dass Spieler wie Manuel Neuer oder Ronaldo oder andere Millionen, dutzende Millionen Menschen über soziale Medien erreichen. Und da spielt das Politische gar keine Rolle. Also das sind Paralleluniversen. Und die fragen sich auch nicht jetzt, ob das Spiel in Baku stattfindet, sondern das könnte auch auf dem Mond stattfinden. Sie gucken die EM und Sie gucken die WM. Und das ist eine bittere Erkenntnis. Aber ich will auch nicht zu negativ sein, das wird ja größer. Und die Kritik ist über die Jahre langsam größer geworden. Und es führt immer noch dazu, dass von diesen zwölf großen Sponsoren der EM jetzt vier aus China kommen, eine aus Katar. Soka ist nicht mehr Sponsor, aber es sind vier aus China. Klar, ist das schwierig zu erklären beim europäischen Turnier, aber so ist es. Und das wird vermutlich auch noch weiter zunehmen.
Ja, und andererseits, ich fand erstmal das Beispiel Manuel Neuer ganz interessant, weil er sich ja nicht mal dann politisch äußert, wenn er sich politisch geäußert hat, ohne es zu wissen. Er hat ja da ein Lied gesungen, was dann vielleicht im Nachhinein nicht so schlau war und hat sich danach dann eher lustig gemacht über die Aufregung darüber. Das war dann auch schon ein sehr deutliches Zeichen der zumindest persönlichen Ignoranz gegenüber manchen Konflikten, die es da gibt. Das muss dann jeder selber bewerten, wie er das findet. Aber was ich bei Aserbaidschan so interessant finde, so spannend finde, ist, ich habe das Gefühl, und da darfst du mich jetzt aber auch gerne korrigieren, wenn du es komplett anders siehst, dass wir da eine andere Wertigkeit haben, als eben zum Beispiel, wenn in Russland ein Sportevent stattfindet. Oder auch meinetwegen in der Türkei mit gewissen Abstufungen noch. Denn Aserbaidschan war doch gar nicht so ähnlich wie Katar vor zehn Jahren. Die waren doch gar nicht auf der sportpolitischen Landkarte und auch nicht auf der touristischen Landkarte. Und genau auf die sind sie ja draufgekommen mit diesen Sportevents. Hat das dann nicht nochmal eine andere Wertigkeit, wenn man sagt, wir unterstützen jetzt quasi schon sehenden Auges die Anfänge und wir wissen ja, welche Ziele damit verfolgt werden. Und jedes Land darf seine eigenen Ziele verfolgen. Das ist ja völlig klar. Aber wenn man dann eben aus guten Gründen bei vielleicht Aserbaidschan sagt, also das ist jetzt aber nicht etwas, was man unterstützen möchte, dann könnte man das ja auch, druff gesagt, auch ganz einfach abdrehen, indem man einfach dahin keine Sportereignisse vergibt.
Ja, Aserbaidschan, ich würde gar nicht sagen, die haben schon einige Sportereignisse auch gehabt. Auch Architektur, da haben renommierte westliche Architekten, haben dort Zentren und Gebäude gebaut. In der Kunst ist es auch so, in der Musik ist es auch so. Das Geld spielt da eine große Rolle. Und es ist auch in so einer Peripherie nicht ganz so zentral. Geopolitisch ist Aserbaidschan, vielleicht jetzt auch aus europäischer Sicht, nicht so ein heikles Thema, auch wenn die mit der Türkei zusammenarbeiten. Im Süden grenzt Iran und Aserbaidschan. Das ist einfach bei uns nicht ganz so auf der Agenda. Ich würde gerne die Frage, wie entscheiden das ja nicht? Das entscheidet ja die UEFA, die anderen Sportverbände. Der Internationale Eishockey-Verband, das ist ein Schweizer, führt den aus einer stolzen Demokratie, die auf direkte Demokratie seit Langem setzt. Und der hat immer noch ganz, ganz spät Lukaschenko getroffen und ihn umarmt und wollte ganz, ganz spät auf öffentlichen Druck die Eishockey-WM dort entziehen. Und der hat auch kritische, ich gebe mal davon aus, die kritischen Medienberichte wahrgenommen. Warum der das nicht macht, das frage ich mich auch. Ob die da in anderen Netzwerken sind oder anderen Werte kanonen, das frage ich mich auch. Weil der kommt ja nicht aus China oder aus Russland oder aus Uzbekistan, sondern er ist ein Schweizer und ist in Europa sozialisiert. Als Menschen dort geknebelt, gefoltert, verhaftet wurden, wollte immer noch die Eiswerke WM in Belarus stattfinden lassen.
Man wird es vielleicht nie erfahren. Vielleicht noch interessant zu wissen für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, es gibt eine Sonderregel der UEFA, nach dem Clubs und Nationalteams aus Armenien und Aserbaidschan nicht gegeneinander spielen dürfen. Das erscheint logisch, aber zeigt ja auch, wie tief da die Gräben sind, wenn nicht mal der Sport, der immer die ganze Welt vereint, zumindest im Marketing spreche, der großen Verbände, wenn nicht mal der Sport es schafft, diese politischen Gräben zu überwinden. Aber dann wisst ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, was es noch zu Baku als Austragungsort zu wissen gibt, auch wenn die Bilder von da werden toll sein. Die Architektur, die du auch schon angesprochen hast, das sieht alles ganz fantastisch aus. Dahinter steckt aber halt dann noch ein bisschen mehr, wie leider so häufig. Wir gießen ein bisschen Wasser in die EM-Suppe, aber so muss es dann vielleicht auch manchmal sein. Wir haben mit Ungarn und Budapest noch einen Standort, an dem auch EM-Spiele ausgetragen werden. Der ist jetzt wieder auch geopolitisch und auch politisch näher an Deutschland heran. Und auch hier sind wir, glaube ich, wieder sehr schnell in einer Diskussion, welche Maßstäbe wir eigentlich anlegen an Austragungsorte. Ich finde Ungarn aber auch deshalb jetzt relevant, weil Ungarn auch generell eine Rolle gespielt hat rund um die Corona-Pandemie. Wir alle erinnern uns an die Spiele zwischen Liverpool und Raber Leipzig, die bei einer Inzidenz von 300 in Budapest stattgefunden haben, einfach weil Willy Orban gesagt hat, das ist alles hier gar kein Problem, kommen Sie gerne, Sie können gerne Ihre Spiele hier machen, wenn die in den anderen Ländern da irgendwelche Einreisebeschränkungen und so weiter haben. Bei uns gibt es das nicht. Ist das so ein Zeichen für einen fast schon pragmatischen Ansatz, wie man sich über den Fußball dann politisch, sportpolitisch positionieren kann?
Ja, also Orban ist als Ministerpräsident innerhalb der Europäischen Union. Stark in der Kritik wird so als nationalistische Außenseite angesehen, weil er Justiz, weil er Medien, weil er Zivilgesellschaft stark an die Leine nimmt und stark in der Kritik ist. Er ist ein großer Fußballfan, hat selbst auch Fußball gespielt. Wenn man das bei Google mal eingibt, Orban, Football, sieht man lustige Fotos, war auch ein passabler Spieler. Und die Legende ist ja auch, dass er mit seinen Gründern, der Fidesz, der seiner Partei 80er, 90er Jahre im selben Team gespielt hat und in seiner Heimatstadt, in einer kleinen Stadt, auch da ist ein wunderschönes Stadion entstanden, in vielen ungarischen Städten, schöne Stadien, Sportakademien, Hallen entstanden, für viel Geld, da gibt es auch Kritik, warum man nicht genauso viel Geld in Bildung oder Medizin steckt. Aber Viktor Orban als Ministerpräsident, der ist Fußballfan. Und klar, durch solche Gesten, wie das England oder das Deutschland die Einreisebestimmung während Corona verschärfen, aber Ungarn macht die Türen auf für Sport, trotz hoher Inzidenz, vielleicht hat er dafür auch Geld genommen, das Stadion in Budapest zu vermieten. Es ist auch so, dass seine Vertrauten in den Clubs sitzen. Manchmal muss man dem vielleicht gar nicht immer nur böse Strategie unterstellen, sondern es sind wirklich leidenschaftliche Fußballer, die mögen den Sport und die wollen sich da das auch als Spielball, als Spielzeug halten. Ich kann empfehlen von David Goldblatt, ein britischer Autor, der hat The Age of Football geschrieben und schreibt auch für den Guardian. Der beschreibt das ganz gut. Die wollten schon lange mal mit Orbán sprechen und sind dann zum Fußball gefahren. Und im Stadion auf der Ehrentribüne ist die Chance, mit noch am größten ihn mal ansprechen zu können. Das gilt auch für andere Politiker. Und auch in Ungarn, das wissen wir, Rechtsruck, Minderheiten, Sinti und Roma, jüdische Menschen, die haben es schwer. Und Ferdinz Varos Budapest, der Rekordmeister, auch da sitzt ein Orbán-Vertrauter seit zehn Jahren an der Spitze. Auch dort ist es auch wie in anderen Ländern so, wenn mal kritische Leute auf die Straße gehen, dann kann man eben auch mit den eigenen Fans, mit den eigenen manchmal auch extrem rechten Fans, da Drecksarbeit verrichten lassen, dass das nicht zu kritisch wird. Aber Ungarn ist wirklich ein Beispiel in der Europäischen Union, wie der Fußball da genutzt wird. Und das geht so weit, dass das Orbán ja, das Wort Geopolitik kann man durchaus verwenden, der möchte ja auch in den Nachbarstaaten einen Einfluss gewinnen. Im Süden von Ungarn, in Kroatien, im Osten von Kroatien, in Osttiek. Auch dort ist mit ungarischen Firmen, nicht nur mit ungarischen Firmen, auch mit anderen, auch ein neues Stadion entstanden. Und wenn man von Viktor Orbán seine Reden hört, der träumt ja schon oft von diesem großen Ungarn, was es ja mal gegeben hat im Königreich Ungarn, also Anfang noch des 20. Jahrhunderts. Es war ja mal ein wesentlich größeres Land, und dann ab und zu sagt er mal sowas, und dann hört man in Kroatien auch genau hin. Wird nicht ganz ernst genommen, aber ist schon irritierend. Und der Fußball ist da auch eine Bühne, das auch zu zeigen. Wenn Ungarn eben auch im Nachbarland Stadion baut.
Da stecken jetzt schon wieder so viele Themen drin. Ich vermute, die Hörerinnen und Hörer sind vor allem über den Einsatz von oft sehr rechten Hooligans aus politischen Gründen so ein bisschen drüber gestolpert. Wir erleben bei Ungarn ja ein bisschen einen, oder was heißt ein bisschen? Ich versuche immer diplomatisch zu sein, vielleicht bin ich manchmal an den falschen Stellen. Wir erleben einen Rechtsruck und auch das systematische Nivellieren von demokratischen Institutionen, wie eben zum Beispiel einer freien Presselandschaft. Das alles erleben wir bei einem EU-Mitgliedstaat, bei dem sich zwar der Staatschef jetzt immer mehr isoliert, aber de facto immer noch mit sehr, sehr vielen Dingen nicht nur mitreden kann, sondern auch mitbestimmen kann in der Europäischen Union. Würdest du denn sagen, man kann das auch am Fußball ablesen, was in Ungarn gerade passiert? Du hast ja gerade auch schon ein drastisches Beispiel genannt.
Es ist fast, würde ich sagen, so ein Vergrößerungsglas. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass Ungarn macht politisch der wichtigste Staat innerhalb der Europäischen Union ist. Und die Fußballliga ist jetzt auch nicht die spektakulärste Liga. Ungarn zählt von seiner glorreichen Geschichte der 50er Jahre. Aber jetzt bei der EM ist er ein Standort. Und noch einmal, klar wird sich Viktor Orbán freuen, dass er da jetzt auf der Bühne ist. Der hat nicht die Allmachtsfantasie, einer der wichtigsten Staatschefs in Europa zu sein. Auf seine Region schaut er schon, auf die Nachbarstaaten. Aber er ist kein Macron und auch keine Merkel. Das weiß er auch. Er ist auch kein... Ich spreche kein Ungarisch, aber was man von Experten so hört, spricht er ja nicht so wie Putin. Oder er gibt sich anders. Aber seinen Laden hat er schon im Griff, um das mal salopp zu formulieren. Sonst würde er nicht nach und nach die Strukturen so sehr verändern. Er ist ja auch schon 11 Jahre an der Macht. Er wird vermutlich auch noch länger an der Macht bleiben, weil er nach und nach alle Strukturen mit Vertrauten austauscht. In den Medien, in der Justiz, in der Kultur, in der Bildung. Es ist quasi bald ein Parteienstart. Wie gesagt, der Fußball ist ein besonders emotionales, ein besonders reichweitenstarkes Vermittlungsmedium für diese Taktik.
Womit man dann ja auch ableiten könnte, wahrscheinlich ist für Viktor Orban die Innenwirkung, dass solche Fußballereignisse in Ungarn stattfinden, wichtiger als die Außenwirkung. Du hast ja schon gesagt, er will wahrscheinlich gar nicht der große Staatsmann sein und weiß auch um die geopolitische Situation. Also würdest du da zustimmen, dass es vor allem darum geht, nach innen ein Zeichen der Stärke zu setzen und sich dann eben auch hinter einem emotionalen Ereignis zu vereinen?
Es ist schwierig, das genau zu vermuten, was er damit genau denkt. Und er ist jetzt auch an einem Punkt, wo er die Macht sicher hat und da kritische Köpfe nicht mehr so zu fürchten hat, wie noch vor einigen Jahren. Und ja, die Medien haben diese Gastspiele, die deutschen Clubs als europäische Solidarität gefeiert, die nicht mehr unabhängigen Medien, zumindest die größeren, da wird sich zeigen auf der EM-Bühne. Und jetzt, wenn der Ball erst mal rollt, wenn die kritischen Beiträge und Interviews vorbei sind, dann werden sich viele Medien auch wieder Zeit nehmen über das ungarische Nationalteam der 50er Jahre, die glorige Zeit, der Pushkast usw. Da wird es wieder ein bisschen weicher. Auch das ist interessant, wo es auch wenig Studien gibt, die das vielleicht bemessen können, ob der Fußball in seiner Öffentlichkeit zu einer tatsächlichen Wertschöpfung beiträgt. Da hat Budapest aus touristischen Gründen das nicht nötig. Es ist eine beliebte und aus Westeuropa stark frequentierte Stadt. Aber auch Ungarn ist ja, auch das frage ich mich jetzt, das ist meine westeuropäische Brille, warum macht das der Orban? Warum geht er in so vielen Punkten auch auf Konfrontation mit der EU? Obwohl er ja in den EU-Fördertöpfen so stark von diesem gemeinsamen Netzwerk abhängt. Aber es scheint zu funktionieren und im Fußball wird er dafür jetzt auch ein bisschen belohnt.
Und dann haben wir ja hier jetzt auch schon eine Schnittmenge des Fußballs zu Rechten bzw. nationalen Tendenzen. Du hast dich ja damit auch schon ausführlich befasst, auch im deutschen Fußball. Würdest du sagen, da ist der Fußball besonders anfällig, für da ein Publikum anzuziehen oder ein Publikum zu haben, das eben auch einem solchen Gedanken gut anhaftet? Oder liegt das jetzt einfach nur daran, was der beliebteste Sport in Europa ist? Und wir hätten das im Basketball in Lettland zum Beispiel, da ist ja Basketballgröße genauso.
Fußball ist seit Jahrzehnten, seit mehr als 100 Jahren in vielen Ländern, die mit Abstand beliebteste Sportart, da konnten sich ganz andere Narrative herausbilden. Und auch in Ungarn und auch in anderen Ländern im östlichen Europa ist es vor allem überwiegend männlich. Es ist in Ungarn, ähnlich wie in Polen oder in der Ukraine, noch nicht so ein Familienevent wie bei uns. Es gibt auch keine Fanprojekte oder wenig linke zivilgesellschaftlich orientierte Ultras. Es ist ein überwiegend männliches, maskulines, chauvinistisches Klientel, was natürlich auch der Sport an sich, das wir gegen die anderen, die Abgrenzung, die Provokation, das ständige Provokante im Spiel, das führt vielleicht auch dazu. Aber es sind dann eben auch, wenn wir mal in Ungarn bleiben, gewisse Milieus, die auch das, jedes Land muss man historisch für sich dann auch betrachten. Auch Ungarn, die es nicht ganz leicht gehabt haben nach dem Zusammenbruch des Ostblocks, auch Korruption in der Regierung. Und dann kam Victor Orban und man kann da auch in die jüngere Geschichte schauen, als er um die Nullerjahre herum dann auch, da gab es ja auch turbulente Szenen, Stürmungen vom Rundfunksender und so weiter. Da waren schon Fußball-Fans dabei. Es war so eine Art auch rechtloser Raum und das konnte man dann weiterentwickeln. Wie gesagt, bei Ferenc Varrocs sitzt ein vieles Vertrauter und auch da haben tolle Kollegen in Ungarn darüber recherchiert und zeigen die Vernetzung. Das sieht man auch in Russland oder auch in den westlichen Balkanstaaten noch mehr, wie sehr Politik und Fußball und dieses junge männliche Publikum da vernetzt ist. Das gibt Vermischung auch mit dem Rotlichtmilieu, Leute, die als Türsteher in Diskotheken arbeiten, die auch in anderen Formen Geld verdienen, was illegalerweise. Die gehen auch zum Fußball, das sind auch Fans, und kann man dann vielleicht relativ leicht auch für extrem rechte oder rechtspopulistische Organisationen gewinnen.
Das martialische, das der Fußball oft hat, kommt ja sicherlich auch noch mit dazu. Aber könnte das nicht ein Ansatzpunkt sein, wenn man jetzt sagt, wir verlangen vom Fußball, in dem Fall wäre es jetzt dann vom Verband UEFA, dass er eben sich schon für mehr einsetzt als nur einem ökonomischen Gewinn in Turnieren, sondern eben auch für eben zivilgesellschaftliche Aktionen, dass das eben zum Beispiel ein Kriterium werden könnte, dass Ausstragungsorte von Turnieren, dass es da Fanprojekte geben muss, dass ein gewisser Teil der Gelder, die eingenommen werden, auch genau dafür verwendet werden. Ich hoffe, da bin ich jetzt nicht so blauäugig, aber ich hätte jetzt die These aufgestellt, dass das im Grunde das einzige ist, was gegen solche rechten Tendenzen innerhalb von Fanszenen nachhaltig wirken kann, wenn man eben für Fanprojekte sorgt, wenn man die Jugendlichen versucht frühzeitig aufzuklären und zu versuchen, dass nicht jeder da sofort in diese Szene hineinrutscht, sondern dass es auch eine Alternative dazu gibt.
Wir kennen und vermutlich können viele von den Hörerinnen das gar nicht mehr hören und sehen, diese Symbolik gegen Racism oder für Vielfalt usw. Diese ewig gleiche Agentursprache, die manchmal auch sehr leer und vage erscheint. Und klar, Symbolik ist gut und sollte ein Mindeststandard sein, aber überdeckt manchmal ja auch die wahren Probleme, weil es vielleicht sogar der unwissenden Publikumsmehrheit suggeriert, die Bosse kümmern sich und wir müssen es selbst nicht machen. Deswegen, wie du sagst, Symbolik macht nur Sinn, wenn es auch mit Inhalten unterfüttert wird. Und wie in Deutschland mehr als 60 Fanprojekte entstanden sind, wo Sozialarbeiter den Fußball als Lockmittel nutzen, um junge Männer vor allem, aber auch Frauen und Mädchen für Jugendhilfe zu gewinnen. Das hat man auch zum Beispiel versucht vor der EM 2008 in Österreich und der Schweiz auch ein bisschen vor Polen und Ukraine 2012. Es ist dort weniger geglückt, aber klar kann man das ganz leicht auch mit einbeziehen in die Ausrichterverträge als Bedingung knüpfen. Und das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, von dem ich glaube, dass nicht nur diese moralischen Idealistischen Reden oder diese Worte wie Fair Play, die leider so inflationär benutzt werden. Wir reden hier von einer Milliardenindustrie, von einem Wirtschaftszweig, der muss einfach straff organisiert werden. Soziales oder politisches, gesellschaftlich relevantes und Geld verdienen müssen sich nicht ausschließen. Man darf auch mit einem Sponsor gemeinsam ein Projekt entwickeln für Klimaschutz oder gegen Rechtsextremismus. Denn es sind nicht NGOs, die das sagen haben, oder Sozialprojekte, die das sagen haben, sondern es sind Rechteinhaber, es sind Bierbrauereien, es sind Wettanbieter, es sind Fluggesellschaften aus den Golfstaaten, die haben das Sagen im Fußball. Und denen fehlt jetzt ohnehin so eine richtige Glaubwürdigkeit, aber auch die müssen eine moderne Gesellschaftspolitik haben. Kann man sagen, waschen die sich damit rein? Ja, aber es gibt vielleicht doch einen Mittelweg. Ich bin pragmatischer geworden in den vergangenen Jahren, weil man sich den Idealismus ein bisschen abtrainiert. Aber es ist eine Kommerzbranche, wo man, glaube ich, kommt in die Vorzimmer von Schäferin, von Infantino, von Rummenigge oder Watzke, nur herein, wenn man sagt, hey, wir haben eine gute Idee, da erreichen wir Menschen und wir können auch ein bisschen Geld damit verdienen. Und wenn das sich irgendwann da durchsetzt, dann ist vielleicht allen irgendwie auch ein bisschen geholfen.
Wobei mit sowas wie Fanprojekten jetzt eher schwer Geld zu verdienen wäre, es wäre eher so ein Verteilen von Geldströmen. Aber teilst du denn meinen Optimismus, dass das ein wirksames Mittel sein kann? Ich meine, man kann ja auch im deutschen Fußball, wir müssen jetzt ja nicht so tun, als ob hier alles ganz toll wäre, als ob wir keine rechten Fanszenen hätten. Da kann man ja sowohl Pro- als auch Contra-Beispiele finden für die These. Fanprojekte können helfen, diese Strukturen ein bisschen aufzubrechen.
Es zeigt in der Landkarte der Fanprojekte dort, wo früh Fanprojekte arbeiten durften, wo sie finanziert wurden, auch von der Kommune, vom Land und vom DFB, wie in Bremen, wie in Leverkusen, wie in Hamburg, wie in Dortmund, dass dort Erfolge sich gezeigt haben, dass Sozialarbeiterinnen, die brauchen lange, um Beziehungen aufzubauen mit jungen Fußballfans, das kostet Zeit. Und in anderen Städten, wo dann relativ spät es sich dazu entschlossen wurde, gibt es immer noch mal Probleme. Aber auch da ist eine hohe Fluktuation, da sind wenige Leute, für viele Fans, das ist eine undankbare Arbeit. Aber es ist ein Beispiel. Das Problem ist auch, sobald wir jetzt in Dresden dann wiederholigens den Aufstieg mit Ausschreitungen auch teilweise begehen, dann kommt die Kritik, wir haben noch ein Fanprojekt, warum gibt es immer noch diese Gewalt? Dadurch entsteht ein Handlungsdruck auf die Sozialarbeiter. Und natürlich ein nicht gezeigter Hitlergruß lässt sich eben schwer als Erfolg verbuchen. Das ist der Nachfall von Prävention. Aber trotzdem glaube ich schon, dass das Früchte trägt, sonst würden andere Länder wie Frankreich, auch wie England, die auch einen anderen Weg gehen, da nicht so neidisch auf die Fanprojekte schauen. Und natürlich gibt es Entwicklungspotenzial, auch die Fanprojekte, haben lange wenig gegen Sexismus gemacht usw. Und wenn wir nach Ungarn oder nach Russland schauen, dann glaube ich, ist der deutsche Fußball wirklich passabel aufgestellt.
Jetzt war jetzt ein kleiner Schwenker. Einen großen Schwenker haben wir noch vor uns. Es ist ein bisschen ein wilder Ritt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich gebe es zu, durch viele verschiedene politische Themengebiete. Ich kann nur nochmal darauf hinweisen, das Buch Machtspieler von Ronny sich zu besorgen und zu lesen. Da bekommt ihr das nochmal ein bisschen in mehr Ruhe und mehr Tiefe vermittelt. Wir sind bei nationalistischen Tendenzen im Fußball. Dann müssen wir noch über zwei Besonderheiten sprechen, die auch mit dieser EM zu tun haben, jetzt aber nicht mehr auf Ausrichterebene. Das eine ist, dass es separatistische Bewegungen auch in Ländern wie Spanien gibt und dass wir Nationalismus im Umfeld von Fußballvereinen, ich würde sagen in einer schon extremeren Form als anderswo, in vielen Ländern des ehemaligen Jugoslawiens erleben. Das ist jetzt eine sehr große Klammer, die ich hier mache. Aber welche Rolle spielt denn da die Verquickung von Politik und Fußball deiner Meinung nach?
Einige Spiele der EM sollten ja ursprünglich in Bilbao stattfinden. Und auch das spanische Nationalteam sollte dort spielen, was ich immer schon als kurios empfunden habe, weil das spanische Nationalteam seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr in Bilbao gespielt hat. Da wären sie vermutlich ausgefiffen worden, im Bastenland. Sogar die Einschaltquoten des Nationalteams sind im Bastenland geringer als in anderen Regionen Spaniens. Weil das Bastenland, wie andere Regionen, aber vor allem das Bastenland, seit Jahrzehnten stolz ist auf seine relative Autonomie. Viele wollen sich sogar ganz loslösen von Spanien. Der Fußball bei Athletic Bilbao vor allem war eng verknüpft mit der Baskischen Nationalistenpartei. Schon 20er, 30er Jahre waren Politiker auch in den Vorständen von Athletic Bilbao und auch in der Diktatur in Spanien unter Franco, die ja rund 40 Jahre andauerte. Vielleicht ist das ein bisschen auch Mythos und Verklärung, aber zumindest konnte man auch ein bisschen die baskische Kultur beim Fußball in der gefühlten Anonymität des Stadions dann auch ausleben. Als Franco gestorben war und das erste Derby danach, oder ich glaube kurz, es war um den Tod herum von Franco in der Mitte der 70er Jahre, Adidik Bilbao gegen Real Sociedad aus San Sebastian, also der zweite große baskische Club. Da haben beide Kapitäne die baskische Flagge in den Anstoßpunkt gerammt. Wenn man heute durch Bilbao geht, da kommt dann diese Szene immer mal wieder entgegen. Das ist diese verklärende Art, was man sich als Mythos wahrscheinlich immer größer wird in den Jahrzehnten der Historisierung danach. Wir haben auch die ETA gehabt, also die Terrororganisation, die Menschen getötet hat für ihr Ziel einer Loslösung. Die hatte einige Hundert Mitglieder, aber eben auch zehntausende Sympathisanten. Und da wurden auch Entführungen und Attentate im Stadion von Athletik zum Teil auch gut geheißen. Und das ist jetzt auch lange her, die ETA gibt es nicht mehr. Mittlerweile ist wieder, das wird man auch wissen, Athletik Belbao spielt nur mit baskischen Spielern. Das wäre so, als wenn der 1. FC Nürnberg nur mit Franken spielt. Also sehr, sehr seltsam, hält sich seit mehr als 80 Jahren in der Primärrevision.
Es wird ja auch so, Entschuldigung, wenn ich da kurz reingehe, aber das finde ich ist so ein typisches Beispiel für ein einerseits, andererseits. Denn das wird ja auch sehr verklärt und gefeiert von vielen Fußballfans, die ich kenne. Und ich hatte auch immer so eine besondere Sympathie dafür, weil sich Athletik Belbao damit ja besonders schwer macht und weil man sich das gleichzeitig vielleicht auch so ein bisschen für den eigenen Verein wünschen würde, dass es mehr mit Spielern aus der Region gearbeitet wird. Dass das aber im Grunde ja ein Nationalismus in seiner Reihenform ist und dass das auch negative Konsequenzen hat für Spieler, die sich dagegen entscheiden, für Belbao zu spielen. Das wird dabei immer ein bisschen ausgeblendet.
Ja, das musste ich auch erstmal in meinen Kopf reinbekommen. Ich war in Belbao und war auch in Katalonien, weil ich den FC Barcelona oder einige Fans getroffen habe. Weil Nationalismus aus deutscher Perspektive ist immer erst mal rechts. Aber die Katalanen verstehen sich als sehr europäisch und als sehr weltoffen und eben auch als nationalistisch. Ähnlich wie die Schotten zum Beispiel. Die Schotten wollen sich ja von der Krone lösen. Viele wollen zumindest auch gegen den Brexit gehen und sehen sich dann auch manchmal als links und eben nicht als... Trotzdem heißt die Scottish Nationalist Party eigentlich eine sozialdemokratische Partei. Kurz als Schwenk. Und in Bilbao ist es manchmal auch so. Stimmt. Also ich habe mit Sid Lowe gesprochen, das ist der Korrespondent des Guardian für den spanischen Fußball. Und der sagte auch, er findet das sympathisch. Das ist so ein erdverwachsener Fußball, der leicht irgendwie an dem man sich andocken kann. Und es ist ja auch in keiner Regel festgeschrieben. Sonst wäre es vielleicht ein Problem für das Verfassungsgericht. Diskriminierung. Gab auch immer mal wieder rassistische Ausfälle gegen schwarze Spieler. Jetzt gibt es einen der größten Stars von Athletik, Inyaki Williams, der ein schwarzer Spieler ist, der Wurzeln hat. Seine Eltern aus Afrika kommen und sein Priester, Inyaki, deswegen wurde er so genannt, ist aber im Baskengland aufgewachsen. Kann man darüber sprechen, ob man das sympathisch findet oder nicht, aber es trägt zu der Mystifizierung dieses Clubs bei. Und wie gesagt, die anderen Punkte wie ETA-Verklärung oder wir kennen noch Bichente Lissardazou, der ist auf der französischen Seite des Baskenglandes groß geworden, war lange beim FC Bayern, der auch sogar eine Schutzsteuerzahnmuster an die ETA. Also es gibt auch die dunkleren Seiten in Bilbao und um den Burgen nochmal zu schließen, wegen der Nicht-Garantie für Zuschauer durch Corona hat die UEFA Bilbao die Spiele entzogen. Sie finden jetzt in Sevilla statt und ich habe mal nachgehört und nachgeschaut, viele Leute im Baskengland freuen sich darüber, dass die EM jetzt doch an ihnen vorbeigeht.
Und das ist auch der Grund, warum es jetzt dann hier in dieser Sendung gelandet ist. Ehrlicherweise hätte ich das ganz gerne mal gesehen, wie sich das geäußert hätte. Aber das kann jetzt vielleicht auch so ein bisschen der Zynismus des Unbeteiligten sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu sehr verharmlose. Also das sind separatistische Bewegungen, die wir aktuell noch haben. Du hast ja auch noch Cataloni genannt. Das sind nochmal ganz eigene Themenkomplexe für sich. Ich möchte jetzt nicht, wenn ich das jetzt alles in einen Kapitel packen, möchte ich damit nicht suggerieren, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das wäre alles dasselbe. Sondern wir können jetzt aber auch nicht bei allem so in die Tiefe gehen. Dann sitzen wir hier noch drei Stunden. Und dann haben wir den Nationalismus. Da hatten wir vorhin mit Manuel Neuer eigentlich schon so ein bisschen die Brücke, über die ich dann aber zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht gehen wollte, in ehemaligen Ländern von Jugoslawien, in dem der Fußball eine ganz krasse Rolle spielt und in dem das auch immer wieder aufflammt, wo es aber meiner Einschätzung nach wegen der Komplexität der Ereignisse da und auch wegen des vorhandenen Nichtwissens, also ich muss mir immer wieder neu anlesen, wie da jetzt eigentlich welche Unabhängigkeit genau verlief und welche Kriege es da genau gab, habe ich immer so das Gefühl, dass man oft Dinge auch gar nicht versteht, wenn man von außen drauf guckt. Und die großen Symboliken, die versteht man, also wenn ein Panzer neben einem Fußballstadion steht und sich die Fans eines Vereins damit ablichten, dann verstehe ich auch, dass da etwas zelebriert wird, was vielleicht mit Dingen zu tun hat, die ich nicht so gut finde und dass das auf einen Krieg referiert. Aber viele andere Symboliken versteht man gar nicht, die zu tun hat. Auch da hilft dein Buch an der Stelle sehr weiter. Und weil wir jetzt ja auch Teilnehmer aus Ländern des ehemaligen Jugoslawiens haben, habe ich das Gefühl, es hat eben doch auch für diese EM eine Relevanz. Ist das nochmal so ein ganz eigener Kosmos, das, was dort unten passiert ist? Also dort unten, Entschuldigung, ein bisschen salopp, aber ihr wisst, wie ich es meine.
Ich würde deine Wahrnehmung absolut teilen. Das war die große Frage. Ich war im Sommer 2019 drei Wochen auf dem westlichen Balkan. Ich habe genauso wie du gedacht, wer war da eigentlich gegen wen, warum haben die sich bekriegt? Und der sozialistische Jugoslawien war so ein spannendes Land, was ja anscheinend für ein sozialistisches Land gar nicht so schlecht funktioniert hat, bis es dann eben in den 80er Jahren durch Wirtschaftskrisen und Spannungen dann doch zu einem zu vielen Nationalismen kam. Und wo hat sich das zuerst gezeigt? Natürlich in den Fußballstadien. Und ich war in Belgrad, in Zagreb. Ich war auch in Kosovo und in Bosnien. Aber vielleicht bleiben wir bei Belgrad, also der Hauptstadt von Serbien. Der rote Stern Belgrad. Da haben sich Anfang der 90er Jahre schon viele Hooligans versammelt. Es gab da diesen legendären Fan-Anführer Raznatović, genannt Akan, der sogar Hooligans rekrutiert hat, die dann in den Krieg gezogen sind, gegen Kroaten, später dann gegen Bosnier, die auch an Kriegsverbrechen beteiligt waren, Vergewaltigungen, Morde. Viele von denen sind durchgekommen. Die wurden nicht strafrechtlich belangt. Raznatović selbst auch und ich, der ist dann später erschossen worden, weil er vermutlich zu viel wusste für die politischen Machthaber. Und heute, du hast den Panzer angesprochen, den habe ich auch gesehen. Da kommen dann die Papas, setzen ihre Kinder auf den Panzer, machen Fotos und Selfies. Das war ein Panzer, der Anfang der 90er Jahre auch in Kroatien beim Krieg aktiv war. Also diese Verharmlosung des Krieges, diese Verhälichung von Kriegsverbrechern. Ratko Bladić, der ging ja gerade wieder durch die Schlagzeilen. Lebenslanger Haft, nachdem er ja spät erst festgenommen wurde, verantwortlich für das Massaker von Srebrenica in Bosnien 95, für den Tod von 8000 Bosnien. Der wird schon noch verklärt und glorifiziert in Stadien Serbiens. Da sieht man auch Bilder von ihm, oder der wird besungen. Das ist das eine. Ich will das jetzt nicht nur, es gibt auch in Serbien auch Kritische, aber erst mal als Einstieg. Aber auch dann war ich in Sarajevo. Das empfehle ich jedem, Sarajevo, die Hauptstadt von Bosnien. Total spannend, nicht nur, weil das Stadion an der Front des Krieges lag, weil man immer noch die Geschichte da sehr nah wahrnehmen kann, sondern weil die Fußballfans das sehr kreativ und offensiv in die Gedenkkultur einnehmen. Also Fans, die getötet wurden während des Krieges, Spieler und so weiter, werden dort aufgegriffen und werden dort einbezogen in die eigene Geschichtsschreibung. Das gilt für Belgrad, das gilt für Sarajevo, auch für Zagreb. Da muss man nur mal mit großen Augen durch die Städte gehen. Graffitis sind da, Wandmalereien, eine sehr detailverliebte Art. Für jeden Fan lohnt sich das mal, so eine Tour zu machen durch den westlichen Balkan.
Und jetzt hast du ja mit Kroatien zum Beispiel auch schon einen WM-Teilnehmer genannt, wo wir das ja auch direkt erlebt haben. Bei der Feier der Vize-Weltmeisterschaft nach der WM 2018 war der Sänger von Thomson einer rechtsnationalen bis rechtsradikalen, meiner Einschätzung nach, Band mit auf dem Wagen der Nationalspieler und durfte mit denen feiern. Da darf ja dann durchaus nicht jeder mit dabei sein. Wie formuliere ich das? Ich will jetzt nicht wieder den Finger rausholen, auch weil ich so zu wenig weiß. Das muss ich einfach zugeben rund um die Balkankriege, die da stattgefunden haben und auch der Vorgeschichte, die ja oft auch noch mit Ethnien zu tun hat, wo ja die Vorgeschichte dann gar nicht jetzt irgendwie im 20. Jahrhundert liegen, sondern noch viel viel früher. Da bin ich einfach nicht tief genug drin. Aber ist das ein problematischer Bereich für dich, dass bei diesen Nationen dann eben auch im Kontext von Europameisterschaften dieser Nationalismus so verherrlicht ausgelebt werden kann?
Es ist wirklich total spannend. Also ich kann jedem das Buch von Richard Mills, ein toller britischer Historiker empfehlen, The Politics of Football in Jugoslavia. Der hat das eigentlich super erzählt. Auch Dario Brentin ist ein anderer Forscher aus Graz. Der hat auch das toll erforscht. Das fand ich eh spannend. Bei jedem Land so viele mittlerweile Autoren, Forscher, Wissenschaftlerinnen, die sich da wirklich toll mit befassen. Und das leider nicht so diese Öffentlichkeit bekommen, die sie eigentlich verdienen. Aber Kroatien ist ein gutes Beispiel. Da kann man ganz lange zurückschauen, auch schon vor dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, wie die Kroaten sich manchmal benachteiligt geführt haben gegen die Serben oder dann auch später, als Kroatien sich auch unabhängig erklärt hat, eine erfolgreiche EM 96, eine erfolgreiche WM 98, die junge kroatische Nation, diese Schachbrettmuster, das Trikot, was plötzlich bekannt geworden ist. Der Präsident damals von Kroatien, Franjo Tutschmann, für den Fußball so ein wichtiges Werkzeug war, der jungen Nation, der hat dann immer gesagt, der Sozialismus, das war eine Epoche, die wollten wir gar nicht. Und da wurden dann auch Parallelen gezogen zu der Zeit während des Zweiten Weltkrieges, ja, als Kroatien teilweise auch mit den Nazis kollaboriert hat. Hoseb Simonic, der frühere Hertha-Spieler, der auch so diesen faschistischen Gruß mal im Stadion gemacht hat. Der Nationalismus ist das schon ausgeprägt in Kroatien. Ich habe da in Zagreb auch eine Fangruppe, eine der wenigen kritischen linken, antirassistischen Gruppen auch besucht, die immer auch Sorge haben, ob sie nicht attackiert werden oder ob sie sich in Gruppen bewegen und kein Risiko eingehen wollen. Dinamo Zagreb, der größte Club. Dinamo, das ist ein Name, der an den Sozialismus erinnert. Tutschmann, der Präsident, der hat auch den Namen umbenannt. Der Club, der sich noch erinnert, die älteren, der hieß ja mal vorübergehend Kroatia Zagreb. Die Fans sind sturmgelaufen. Tutschmann hat gesagt, wer diesen Namen Dinamo weiter sagt, das ist ein Agent aus Belgrad. Als Tutschmann gestorben war, hat man diesen Club aus Kroatia Zagreb, wie den Dinamo Zagreb umbenannt. Das sieht man. Viele rechtsoffene Fans nutzen diesen Namen, der an das sozialistische Jugoslawien erinnert. Vieles passt nicht zusammen, aber dann wird passend gemacht. Das ist das Interessante am Fußball, nicht nur in Kroatien.
Ach, es ist ein komplexes Thema. Um das zu einem vorläufigen Ende in dieser Sendung zu führen, nach all den Dingen, die du angesprochen hast, und wir konnten viele Themenbereiche auch nur anreißen, vielleicht fällt es auf fruchtbaren Boden da draußen. Ich werde auch die von dir angesprochenen Lektüren unter anderem in den Show-Notes verlinken. Dein Buch habe ich jetzt schon oft genug empfohlen, das kommt natürlich auch noch mit rein. Was würdest du denn jetzt für ein Fazit ziehen bezogen auf diese EM? Ich hatte vor dieser Sendung EM der Autokraten zu nennen. Kann man das so stehen lassen? Oder picke ich mir da nicht vielleicht auch einfach etwas leicht Kritisierbares heraus und es ist dann vielleicht doch gar nicht so problematisch zu sehen, wie es der Titel vielleicht suggeriert?
Ich glaube, wir haben ganz gut die Waage gehalten, dass wir da nicht nur negativ waren. Bei mir war es so, dass ich als Sportreporter echt mal eine Zeit hatte, wo ich auch keine Lust mehr hatte auf diese kommerzielle Branche. Und ich für die letzten vier, fünf Jahre mir diese internationalen Themen auch suche, weil ich Lust habe, über den Fußballpolitischen Entwicklung in Ländern mir zu erschließen und hoffe, dass es auch einem größeren Publikum auch gefällt. Und wie gesagt, auch in autokratischen Ländern gibt es immer auch interessante, Ja, China, selbst Katar in den Golfstaaten, ich bin dahin gereist und bin danach immer auch differenziert zurückgekommen und manchmal mit noch mehr Fragen als Antworten. Es ist immer ein ganz tolles Gefühl, in ein Land zu reisen und zu merken, die eigenen Vorurteile werden gebrochen. Das ist toll. Wir haben auch zum Beispiel Glasgow einen Spielort. Wenn man da die Geschichte sieht, Celtic Glasgow katholisch geprägt, die Glasgow Rangers protestantisch, das spielt der Nordirland-Konflikt noch eine Rolle. Wir haben die Besonderheit, ich möchte es kurz erwähnen, dass das Land Großbritannien, ein Land, eine Staatsbürgerschaft, aber vier Nationalteams hat, England, Schottland, Wales, Nordirland und drei davon sogar für die EM qualifiziert sind, zwei England und Schottland in London gegeneinander spielen werden. Da ist so viel Geschichte dabei, da ist Religion dabei, da ist natürlich auch Frotzelei dabei. Und da wird über Brexit gesprochen, über Nordirland und es gibt uns eine Möglichkeit, über so vieles zu sprechen und das ist doch total total toll. Und wenn ich so in die internationalen Medien schaue, dann hat das eine Reichweite mittlerweile und es gibt mittlerweile so viele tolle Podcasts wie deinen, wo dafür einfach Öffentlichkeit hergestellt wird. Und ich glaube, dass als, ich glaube, ich bin ein bisschen älter als du, als ich angefangen habe Fußball-Fans zu sein, da war das überhaupt nicht der Fall. Und jetzt haben wir sozusagen das Schulbuch Fußball, was gar nicht so sehr wie Schule wirkt, sondern was Spaß macht. Und das ist doch eigentlich für die kommenden vier Wochen nicht der Schlechteste.
Das heißt, so sollten wir es sehen. Wir genießen die EM, wir hinterfragen aber auch und nehmen es zum Anlass, dann uns an dem, was wir da sehen, fortzubilden. Und dann ist es wie die Netflix-Doku, die uns auf einmal in ein Thema reingezogen hat. Und plötzlich wissen wir alles über Kochen. Und so ist es dann mit Fußball und Politik auch, ja?
In der Tat. Und es macht ja auch Spaß, das mit Freunden zu machen. Also ich freue mich darauf. Wobei manchmal die Erfahrung war auch so, dass sobald so ein Turnier erst mal wieder läuft, rollt er nur noch der Ball. Vielleicht ist es... Wir haben ja einige Jahre auch davor gehabt, in dem wir darüber sprechen könnten. Und die große Hoffnung ist, dass man vielleicht nach der WM-Cutter, nach der EM, teilweise in Baku auch vielleicht noch mal danach hinschaut und das nicht vergisst.
Das ist doch ein schönes Schlusswort. Ronny, ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich. Es ist nicht ganz deine Uhrzeit, hast du zum Anfang dieses Gesprächs gesagt. Ich vermute, es wurde nicht noch mehr zu deiner Uhrzeit. Umso mehr. Ganz herzlichen Dank für deine Zeit, dass du hier mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Vielen Dank, dass du dem Thema so ein Forum gibst. Und ja, jetzt bin ich eigentlich noch hell wach und ich hoffe, dass ich der höhere, viele höhere Bands vielleicht auch morgens oder in der Mittagszeit hören. Aber es sei gesagt, wir nähern uns Mitternacht und wir arbeiten hier noch spät am Abend für das Publikum. Aber ich hoffe, dass das Publikum das Mittags- oder Morgens-Hört wach und frisch und voller Geduld.
Sie werden es sogar erst morgens hören können. Ich musste zwischendurch die Entscheidung treffen, da morgen früh wieder Schule ist für die Zwillinge, kann ich nicht mehr heute Nacht veröffentlichen. Also es wird erst morgen Vormittag erscheinen. Sie werden es mit frischem Kopf hören müssen. Ronny Blaschke, Ed Ronny Blaschke auch auf Twitter. Ich empfehle euch sehr, folgt ihm dort. Es lohnt sich und lest seine Bücher. Sie wurden nicht ohne Grund ausgezeichnet. An der Stelle ist vielleicht auch nochmal der Hinweis auf den Podcast Fußball und Macht zu machen, bei dem du ja auch involviert warst. Den haben wir schon mal vorgestellt, aber auch den werde ich nochmal verlinken. Ich werde auch ganz viele andere Bücher in den Show Notes verlinken als Anschub dann für eure Weiterbildung. Danke dir, lieber Ronny. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich hoffe, dieses Tribünengespräch hat euch gefallen. Wir freuen uns sehr über Feedback unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und dann bin ich doch sehr gespannt, wie wir diese EM dann alle konsumieren werden und was wir eigentlich zur WM22 dann hier im Rasenfunk machen. Da bin ich immer noch unentschlossen. Da hat der Ronny jetzt auch wieder dafür gesorgt, dass ich wieder neue Gedanken dazu hatte. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Wir hören uns hier im Rasenfunk. Passt auf euch auf. Bis bald. Macht's gut.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.